programming throwdown episode 105 a chatbot with a brain with peter voss take it away jason hey everybody so um yeah I think this is gonna be an amazing episode. I think a lot of people are amazed when they work with chatbots. So either you call them on the phone and you get that automatic response or, you know, even just, you know, having a putting a search query into Google a way, is a very kind of short-form chat. And so this idea of, like, this human-computer interaction is something that's really taken off. I mean, so many people have Alexa in their home, right? And so, you know, I'm super excited about this area. And we have Peter Voss here, who's the founder and CEO of iGo.ai.
Programming Throwdown 第 105 期：拥有大脑的聊天机器人，嘉宾 Peter Voss。开始吧，Jason。嘿，大家好，嗯，我觉得这会是非常精彩的一期节目。我想很多人在与聊天机器人交互时都会感到惊叹。无论是打电话时听到的自动语音回复，还是在谷歌上输入搜索查询，这其实都是一种简短形式的聊天。这种人机交互的概念确实已经非常流行了。我的意思是，很多人家里都有 Alexa，对吧？所以我对这个领域感到非常兴奋。今天我们请到了 iGo.ai 的创始人兼首席执行官 Peter Voss。
And we're going to just dive really deep into this topic, how this actually works, cover a lot of different sort of areas here. And so thank you so much for coming on the show, Peter. Yeah, thanks for having me. Cool. How are you surviving with COVID and everything else? How are you dealing with the quarantine? It's actually worked surprisingly well for our company. We, you know, we used to work in a very small office crammed together and do a lot of brainstorming.
我们将深入探讨这个话题，了解它是如何运作的，并涵盖许多不同的领域。非常感谢你来到节目中，Peter。好的，谢谢邀请。太棒了。你和大家在疫情期间过得怎么样？你是如何应对隔离的？实际上，这对我们公司来说效果出奇地好。你知道，我们过去常在一个非常狭小的办公室里挤在一起，进行大量的头脑风暴。
And now everybody's working remote and I thought it would really be very detrimental. And we somehow managed to adapt. So I've got an awesome team and so far so good. We still miss some of this close collaboration brainstorming, and I think we're missing out on some of that. So hopefully we'll be able to get back to that. Yeah.
现在每个人都在远程办公，我原以为这会非常不利。但我们不知何故设法适应了。我有一个很棒的团队，目前为止一切顺利。我们仍然怀念那种紧密的协作和头脑风暴，我觉得我们确实失去了一些东西。希望我们能尽快恢复那种状态。是的。
Have you tried any of these whiteboarding, like collaborative whiteboarding apps? We've tried some over, you know, sort of over the months, but nothing. Yeah, I don't think we have quite figured out how to get the same dynamic as people sitting around the table. Yeah, we've had the same experience where we've tried a few of them. There's actually a physical one that Microsoft sells, or maybe it's Google. I don't remember, but there's a physical board where you write and as people write, it shows up. Yeah. Hugely expensive. Yeah. Yeah. It's insanely expensive. And there's delay. So some people who are listening to the show probably can't see this. But in this case,
你尝试过任何像协作白板这样的应用吗？过去几个月我们尝试过一些，但没什么用。是的，我觉得我们还没找到那种像大家围坐在桌子旁一样的动态感。是的，我们也有同样的经历，尝试过几个。其实微软或者谷歌卖一种实体白板，我不记得是哪家了，但那是一种实体板，你在上面写字，其他人写的时候也会显示出来。是的，非常昂贵。是的，确实贵得离谱。而且有延迟。所以听节目的朋友可能看不到，但在这种情况下，
I'm in my house. Patrick's on a spaceship. You can imagine the kind of delay that that's going to have, you know, so many light years. But, you know, you feel it, you know, when you're working with your team and you write something or you see someone write something delayed, it's kind of this uncanny valley where it almost would be better if it just had an artificial delay. It wasn't just kind of always following you a little bit behind.
我在家里，Patrick 在宇宙飞船上。你可以想象那种延迟，毕竟隔了那么多光年。但你知道，当你和团队一起工作时，你写下东西或者看到别人写的东西有延迟，你会感觉到那种“恐怖谷”效应，如果它能人为地设置一个延迟，而不是总是慢半拍，效果可能会更好。
Anyway, it is what it is. So we'll, you know, have'll have to just live with that. But yeah, we're doing okay. Cool. And so iGo.ai focuses on conversational assistance. And so how does this work? Is it kind of like a single assistant that you build that many people use, or do you have custom assistants know assistants for different you know consumers yeah so our product is actually now in sort of second
总之，事实就是这样。所以我们只能接受它。但我们目前还过得去。太棒了。那么 iGo.ai 专注于对话式助手。这是如何运作的？是你构建了一个供多人使用的单一助手，还是你为不同的消费者提供了定制的助手？是的，我们的产品目前处于第二代。
major generation we launched the first generation actually in 2008 12 years ago and there we focused on automating call center calls intelligently you know everybody hates calling into a call center and having a robot, you know, press one for this or, you know, doesn't understand you. So that's the market. We basically, these things are called IVRs, interactive voice response. And basically what we're offering in a company called Smart Action is an IVR with a brain. So it remembers what you said earlier in the conversation. You know, it has deeper passing, deeper understanding, has some reasoning ability and so on. So they're much better conversations.
我们实际上在 2008 年推出了第一代，也就是 12 年前。当时我们专注于智能自动化呼叫中心电话。你知道，每个人都讨厌打给呼叫中心，然后听到机器人说“按 1 选择这个”或者它根本听不懂你在说什么。这就是市场。我们提供的产品叫 Smart Action，本质上是一个“有大脑”的 IVR（交互式语音应答）。它能记住你在对话中之前说过的话。它有更深层的解析、更深层的理解，并具备一定的推理能力等等。所以它们的对话质量要好得多。
That was our first generation focusing on automating call centers. The second generation with Aigo AI, we just launched commercially last year. Here we're focusing actually on chat channels initially, because there's huge demand. That's the biggest sort of growth area in customer interaction. And we are focusing on enterprise applications right now. So, you know, large companies that want to give hyper-personalized customer support. But we're also targeting things like a personal assistant for somebody who wants to manage their diabetes, for example. For coaching, we're working with a company that does VR coaching. And they basically need an intelligence engine to to simulate the conversation that you're having so there are many different applications but right now our focus is on enterprise working
那是我们专注于自动化呼叫中心的第一代产品。第二代产品 Aigo AI 是我们去年才商业化推出的。在这里，我们最初专注于聊天渠道，因为需求巨大。这是客户交互领域最大的增长点。我们目前专注于企业应用。也就是说，那些希望提供超个性化客户支持的大型公司。但我们也针对个人助手等领域，比如帮助管理糖尿病的助手。在辅导方面，我们正在与一家做 VR 辅导的公司合作。他们基本上需要一个智能引擎来模拟你正在进行的对话。所以应用场景有很多，但目前我们的重点是与大型企业合作。
with large enterprise companies getting into consumer market we'd obviously love to have our product available to to the consumer but it's just very hard to break into that market. You know, it's very expensive, very risky. So we're choosing to first do, you know, commercial applications. Yeah, that makes sense. And so how I imagine this, and tell me if I missed the mark here, but so you go on, let's say, Amazon. Actually, we did this the other day where we had to return something to Amazon, and we had a bit of a complicated return.
进入消费市场，我们当然希望产品能面向消费者，但打入那个市场非常困难。你知道，成本很高，风险很大。所以我们选择先做商业应用。是的，这很有道理。那么我是这样想象的，如果我理解错了请纠正我，比如你上亚马逊。其实我们前几天刚做过，我们需要退货给亚马逊，退货过程有点复杂。
And so they said, would you like to chat to a customer service representative? And so we did, and we had this quick chat within the Amazon website. And then they were able to sort of sort it out for us, right? And so this is kind of the market where you say, someone says they're going to chat with a person on a website, but it's actually this bot. And then at some point, maybe it hands off to a person if it needs to.
他们问：“你想和客服代表聊天吗？”于是我们照做了，在亚马逊网站内进行了快速聊天。然后他们帮我们解决了问题，对吧？所以这就是你所说的市场，有人说要和网站上的人聊天，但实际上是机器人。然后在某些情况下，如果需要，它可能会转接给人工。
That's exactly it. And basically, we're taking that whole experience to another level, because the current chatbot technology just has severe limitations for doing things like that. And I think we'll talk at length about what those are and why they are. But yes, that's exactly the kind of applications we have. And moreover, we look for applications that are hyper-personalized to the individual. Now, what I mean by that is repeat. It's more likely that they actually repeat engagement so that you can also have build on the loyalty of the customer. Or it's like, you know, as I said, diabetes management where you'd actually be using it every day. But it could also be, you know, your your bank or or a company that you I mean, Amazon would be a good example that you you may be interacting with on a regular basis. And it gets to know you. And it's hyper-personalized to you as an individual, not as a statistic of a demographic
正是如此。基本上，我们正在将整个体验提升到一个新的水平，因为目前的聊天机器人技术在处理这类事情时有严重的局限性。我想我们会详细讨论这些局限性是什么以及原因。但是的，这正是我们拥有的应用场景。此外，我们寻找的是对个人进行超个性化的应用。我的意思是，重复性。他们更有可能进行重复互动，这样你也可以建立客户忠诚度。或者就像我说的，糖尿病管理，你每天都会用到它。但也可能是你的银行，或者像亚马逊这样的公司，你可能会经常与之互动。它会了解你，并针对你个人进行超个性化，而不是把你当作人口统计学中的一个统计数字。
group. But it remembers what conversations you've had and takes that into account. It uses that as context, what you said earlier, what you said last week, what, you know, what kind of interactions you've had before. And that can be omni-channel as well, that, you know, our conversational AI can take into account, you know, other interactions you've had via email or, you know, other channels as well. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I mean, one thing that I was thinking about, actually, when we were having this chat with this either customer service representative or AI. We don't we don't know because we probably failed that Turing test. But when we were having this chat, one thing that went through my mind was how, you know, when I was, let's say, early in university, I had tons of time. And so I wouldn't mind sort of like sort of kind of optimizing these kinds of
它会记住你进行过的对话，并将其纳入考量。它将此作为上下文，包括你之前说过的话、上周说过的话，以及你之前进行过什么样的互动。这也可以是全渠道的，我们的对话式 AI 可以考虑到你通过电子邮件或其他渠道进行的互动。是的，这完全说得通。其实我在和那个客服代表或 AI 聊天时想到一件事。我们不知道它是谁，因为我们可能没通过图灵测试。但当我们聊天时，我脑子里闪过一个念头：当我刚上大学时，我有大把的时间。所以我不在乎去优化这些事情，
things like okay let's figure out the best way to do this let's um uh you know we could do different things we could try different things you know like send us one and if it doesn't work then you will send it back he says and now you know things are just so chaotic right now there's just so many things going on you know we have kids we have all these other people sort of in the house and so um now it's like you know just send me all three things and we'll just pick the one that works and said like time is much more important and uh um you know and that's an example of where sort of the customer context really matters because different people have different sort of states of mind when they might be doing the same thing, such as returning a product and trying
比如“让我们找出最好的方法”，我们可以尝试不同的东西，比如“先寄给我们一个，如果不合适再退回去”。而现在，你知道，事情太混乱了，有很多事情要处理。我们有孩子，家里还有其他人。所以现在的情况是，直接把三样东西都寄给我，我们选一个能用的就行。时间变得重要得多。这是一个客户背景非常重要的例子，因为不同的人在做同一件事（比如退货并尝试获取另一个产品）时，心态可能完全不同。
to get another one. Yeah, absolutely. Context is so important. So even, you know, even if you talk to a human, they, I mean, they wouldn't remember what other conversations you've had. You know, they might look it up in their CRMM but normally there isn't time for them to do that but with an intelligent assistant like like we providing it's it's as if you had a dedicated support person on the other side that actually remembers the last conversation you had in a good example there is you know for example telco companies where you might have problems with your cable or whatever. So you called yesterday and you had a problem and then, you know, suggested, well, try this, you know, try moving the router and put it in a different position or whatever.
是的，绝对是。背景非常重要。所以即使你和人类交谈，他们也不会记得你进行过的其他对话。他们可能会在 CRM 中查找，但通常没有时间这样做。但有了像我们提供的这种智能助手，就好像你身边有一个专门的支持人员，他真的记得你上次的对话。一个很好的例子是电信公司，你可能在电缆或其他方面遇到问题。你昨天打过电话，遇到了问题，然后对方建议“试试这个，尝试移动路由器并把它放在不同的位置”等等。
So, you know, next day you call in and then it can say, well, did that help? You know, and say, no, well, you know, I know you've already tried rebooting it. So we want to ask you to do that again, you know, and say, no, well, you know, you've already, I know you've already tried rebooting it. So we want to ask you to do that again, you know, and so that's the kind of, it's even better than with a human because, you know, I go or whatever chatbot with a brain that you have will remember the conversations you've had and what you've done and what you've tried and what you've spoken about and what equipment you have, you know, whether it's been, is on the latest version and, you know, it can do tests, automated tests. It can say, hey, let me test the line.
所以第二天你再打进去，它就可以说：“那有帮助吗？”然后你说：“没有。”它会说：“我知道你已经尝试重启它了。所以我们不会再要求你那样做。”这就是那种体验，它甚至比人类更好，因为 Aigo 或任何你拥有的“有大脑”的聊天机器人会记住你进行过的对话、你做过的事情、你尝试过的方法、你谈论过的内容以及你拥有的设备，比如它是否是最新版本。它可以进行测试，自动测试。它可以说：“嘿，让我测试一下线路。”
And, you know, all of that can happen smoothly and efficiently. Whereas I know we've been working with companies like that. And usually these calls, these service calls, take half an hour, take an hour with a human agent. And it's just like super frustrating, you know? Yeah, yeah. Even resetting your password at a bank, you know? It's like insane of what you have to, what hoops you have to jump through, you know?
所有这些都可以顺畅高效地完成。而我知道我们一直在与这样的公司合作，通常这些服务电话与人工代理通话需要半小时到一个小时。这真的超级令人沮丧，对吧？是的，是的。即使是在银行重置密码，你必须经历的那些繁琐程序简直不可理喻。
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, we had something recently where, yeah, I mean, the short story was yeah we we kept getting asked for different information and we were in the car and we were kind of in a hurry so we had some mixture of the information but not all of it and then that caused you know some fraud thing to get triggered which meant that then you know they shut down the whole account and then things got a hundred times worse. It would have been much better to just know, you know, you could even through the phone, you could know that, I mean, we were calling through the app, through the bank app. So the bank actually could know that we're in the car.
是的，是的。我们最近遇到过类似的情况，简短地说，我们一直被要求提供不同的信息，当时我们在车里，很匆忙，所以我们只带了一部分信息，而不是全部。这导致触发了某种欺诈警报，这意味着他们关闭了整个账户，事情变得糟糕了一百倍。如果他们能知道，甚至通过电话，你甚至可以通过银行 App 打电话。所以银行其实可以知道我们在车里。
They could look at the accelerometer on the phone and say, okay, maybe we shouldn't be asking for documents that this person just wouldn't have in their car right now. So let's dive into that from a technical standpoint. You know, this is a really complicated area. This is one of the most interesting areas for me personally, this idea of knowledge representation, right? And so, you know, what we've seen over the years are sort of two distinct approaches, both kind of evolving separately, in my opinion, separately, and people constantly trying to sort of harmonize them. But I haven't seen anything. And these two representations are, you know, the symbolic representation. So imagine, you know, expert systems like Open Psych, the what was it called, the knowledge graph at Google, DBpedia. So all of these sort of
他们可以查看手机上的加速度计，然后说：“好吧，也许我们不应该要求这个人现在在车里根本拿不出来的文件。”那么，让我们从技术角度深入探讨一下。这是一个非常复杂的领域。对我个人来说，这是最有趣的领域之一，即知识表示的概念。所以，多年来我们看到的是两种截然不同的方法，在我看来它们是各自独立发展的，人们不断尝试将它们协调起来。但我还没看到什么成果。这两种表示法是：符号表示。想象一下，像 OpenCyc 这样的专家系统，谷歌的知识图谱，DBpedia。所有这些用于知识的图形结构。你可以使用统计方法来生成这些结构。但归根结底，你得到的是某种结构或数据库，对吧？而在另一端，你有这种嵌入（embedding）的概念。所以如果你看看 OpenAI 的 GPT-3，或者 BERT 或任何其他模型，你最终得到的是一层又一层的嵌入。这些嵌入是某种投影，
graphical structures for knowledge. And you can use statistical methods to sort of generate these structures. But at the end of the day, what you're left with is kind of this sort of structure or database, right? And then on the other end, you have this sort of embedding idea. So if you look at, you know, GPT-3 from OpenAI, if you look at, you know, BERT or any of these other models, you end up with just layers and layers and layers of embeddings. And so these embeddings are kind of projections
进入某个潜在空间。所以，我认为这两者都非常强大。我的意思是，我们已经看到语言翻译中出现了非凡的成果，例如，它们输入一种语言的单词序列，进入这个巨大的嵌入汤中，然后解码器输出另一种语言的单词，效果非常好，令人惊叹。但是，正如你之前提到的，很难进入那个汤里说“你知道什么”。很难从这个嵌入中提取出“哦，这个人之前在路由器上遇到了问题”。所以一旦进入那个嵌入空间，它就变成了一个黑盒，对吧？所以我注意到在 iGo.ai 上，他们谈论了很多关于深度学习及其挑战的内容。是的，我完全能理解。我认为你最终得到的是一个表达能力很强，但可解释性不强的系统。那么你对整个动态有什么看法？是的，这里有很多东西需要拆解。这真的取决于你的应用，统计模型有多大用处。对于简单的刺激-响应
into some latent space. And so, you know, I think both of these think both of these are extremely powerful, right? I mean, we've seen extraordinary things come out of language translation, for example, where they feed in a sequence of words in one language, it goes into this huge soup of embeddings, and then a decoder emits words in the other language and it works remarkably well amazingly well um but you know to to the point you made earlier it's very hard to go into
类型的事情，比如搜索或常见问题解答，如果你有正确的训练数据，并且标记正确，那么它可能非常强大。所以这可能是处理这类事情的正确工具。但统计方法存在一些非常根本的局限性，至少在它们目前的使用方式上是这样。我可以强调的一个关键点是，它无法实时交互式学习。你基本上是在工厂里训练模型，然后部署它。但当你部署它时，它是只读的。这对任何智能对话来说都是致命的。我的意思是，如果你有一个个人助理，如果你在和另一个人交谈，你
that soup and say what do you know like it's very hard to extract from this embedding like oh this person uh you know had an issue with their router earlier And so it's sort of like once you go into that embedded space, it becomes this kind of black box, right? And so I noticed on the, you know, on iGo.ai, they talk a lot about, you know, deep learning and the challenges there. And yeah, I totally, you know, can level with that. I think that you end up with this system that's very expressive, but not very interpretable. And so what are your thoughts on that whole dynamic? Yeah, so there's a lot, quite a lot to unpack there. It, you know, it really depends on the application that you have, how useful, let me call them statistical models are. And, you know, for sort of a simple stimulus response
说了些什么，而下一句，对方完全没有识别出你刚才说的话，或者只是胡言乱语。我的意思是，让我们举一个五岁孩子都能轻松处理的例子。如果我说六个词：“我姐姐的猫 Spock 怀孕了。”一个五岁的孩子会立刻知道：Peter 在说话，我有一个姐姐，姐姐有一只猫，猫的名字叫 Spock。你可能从名字以为它是公的，然后你听到它怀孕了，我就知道它是母的。所以这些信息对人类和任何智能对话 AI 来说都是立即可用的。它也应该如此。
type thing, like a search or FAQ or, you know, something like that, that can be very powerful if you have the right training data and, you know, it's tagged correctly and so on. So that can be, you know, just very, it's the right tool for that. But there are some really fundamental limitations of statistical methods, certainly the way they're employed right now. And one of the key ones I can highlight is that it cannot learn interactively in real time. You basically train the model at the factory, as it were, and then you deploy it. But when you deploy it, it's read-only. And that's just a death blow for any intelligent conversation that you have. I mean, if you had a personal assistant, if you were talking to another human and you
所以下一句可能是：“她真的很大。”好吧，她，猫很大，因为她怀孕了。或者我们可能会问：“小猫什么时候出生？”这种事情是完全可能的。而且这很简单。我的意思是，从人类的角度来看，这是微不足道的。你期望在对话中记住什么，不是统计性地记住，而是真正地整合你听到的内容，立即将其整合到你的知识库、知识图中。而对于统计系统，它们甚至无法学习。当然，市面上绝大多数系统根本无法学习，无法进行一次性学习（one-shot learning）、交互式学习，实时学习。
said something, and the next sentence, there'd be no recognition of what they've said, or it would just be some gobbled kind of thing you know i mean let's take something that is trivial for a five-year-old child if i say just five words six words you know my sister's cat spock is pregnant you know so a five-year-old child wouldn't immediately know okay peter is speaking i have a sister a sister has a cat the cat's name is spock you might think it's male from the name, and then you hear it's pregnant. I know it's female. So that information is immediately available to a human and to any intelligent conversational AI. It should be as well.
所以你基本上已经出局了。但即使它们能做到，它们也需要一个推理引擎来判断：“好吧，我刚才听到的知识实际上适合放在我的知识图谱的什么位置？”当然，作为一个黑盒，你根本不可能知道如何将它放入你的网络中。这是一项不可能完成的任务。所以对于进行智能对话来说，这完全是一个死胡同。你确实需要一个不透明的知识图谱，并且需要一个推理引擎，能够进行一次性学习。我的意思是，我们在图像学习中也看到了同样的局限性，即使
So the next sentence might be, she's really big. Okay, well, she, the cat's big, because she's pregnant, you know, or we might ask, when will the kittens arrive? You know, and that sort of thing is just impossible. And it's trivial. I mean, it's trivial from from a human point of view, what you expect in a conversation to remember what to remember, and not statistically, but to actually integrate what you hear to immediately integrate into your knowledge base knowledge graph that information and with statistical systems a they cannot even learn uh certainly the the bulk of the ones that are out there they simply cannot learn uh do one-shot learning interactive learning um, you know, in real time.
这不是我们目前关注的领域。但同样，一个孩子通过看一张长颈鹿的照片就能学会什么是长颈鹿，并且能够识别玩具长颈鹿、粉色长颈鹿、小长颈鹿等等，看一张照片就没问题。而深度学习需要成百上千个例子，即便如此，它也很容易被愚弄。所以使用没有一次性学习、没有推理参与的大数据统计方法，在根本上是有问题的或局限的。这很有道理。如果我能插一句，向听众解释一下什么是一次性学习。这是一种竞赛，你可以带上任何你想要的机器学习模型，
So you're already dead in the water, basically, you know, from that. But even if they could, they would need a reasoning engine as well to say, okay, where does that knowledge that I've just heard actually fit into my knowledge graph? Right. And, of course, I'm being a black box i mean it's like impossible to know how you would even you know where you would put that into in in your in your network it's like an impossible task to do that so so it's really a complete dead end for having intelligent conversations you really do need um a knowledge graph that is not opaque and that can you have a reasoning engine that you can have one-shot learning and i mean we see the same limitations in uh in image learning even not
你可以对这个模型做任何事。你可以在谷歌的每一张图片上训练它。你可以做任何你想做的事。但关键是，当你参加这个比赛时，他们会给你看五张动物图片，并告诉你这些动物是什么。它们都是不同的。比如长颈鹿、猫、老鼠、狗。然后就结束了。所以你必须仅凭一个例子，就能从一堆长颈鹿、猫、老鼠和狗中分辨出它们。
that it's not an area we're focusing on now but you know again uh a child can learn a giraffe by seeing one picture of a giraffe uh and it'll be able to recognize toy giraffes you know pink giraffes and you know baby giraffes and and and so on no problem with one one picture you know with deep learning you need you know hundreds or thousands of examples and and even then it can easily be be fooled so there's something something just fundamentally wrong with or limiting using big data statistical approaches that don't have one-shot learning, that don't have reasoning involved. That makes sense. If I could interject for a moment and just explain to the audience what one-shot learning is. It's this idea where imagine sort of a competition where you can bring any machine learning model you want,
我对这个领域了解不多，我不是计算机视觉专家，但我确实看过斯坦福大学李飞飞关于这种一次性或少样本学习（few-shot learning）的一些工作。我想他们所做的是，正如我之前建议的那样，训练这个巨大的模型，试图理解宇宙中可见的一切事物的核心本质和结构。我的意思是，我很难理解这一点。但是，他们采取了这种“汤”的方法，对吧？同样，我认为在图像的一次性学习方面可能可行，但同样，可解释性为零。
and you could have done anything to this model. You could have trained it on every image in Google. You could do whatever you want. But the catch is when you go to this competition, they're going to show you, let's say, five pictures of animals and tell you what those animals are. And they're all going to be different. Say giraffe, cat, mouse, dog, right? And then that's it. So you're going to have to disambiguate, you know, a ton of giraffes, cats, mice, and dogs from each other just from seeing one example.
是的。甚至还有零样本学习（zero-shot learning），这意味着你通过思考，基本上通过认知过程，本质上是推理，就能弄清楚事情，学习新事物。你拥有一些信息，然后从中进行综合，实际上得出了一些新的信息。这也与自动概念形成有关，能够看到某事物的几个例子。我以前从未见过三轮车，然后你看到一个有三个轮子的东西，你只需要很少的例子，就能形成这个新概念。你可能以前见过自行车和
And so I don't know too much about this area either. I'm not a computer vision person, but I did see some work from Fei-Fei Li at Stanford on this one-shot or few-shot learning. And I think what they do is, as I suggested earlier, they train this giant model that tries to understand sort of the, I guess, the core essence and structure of everything that could be seen in the universe. I mean, I don't really, it's hard to wrap my head around that. But, you know, they take this sort of soup approach, right? And again, I think it might work in terms of you might, it might, the one-shot learning for image might be doable, but then again, there's zero interpretability.
汽车等等，你可以很快形成那个概念。别人甚至可以向你解释，即使你以前从未见过。你以前从未见过三轮车。有人说：“是的，它有点像自行车或摩托车，但它后面或前面有两个轮子。”所以，是的。当然，事情的另一面是，有趣的是，DARPA 几年前开始做一些演讲，谈论 AI 的第三波浪潮，
Right. Yeah. And even you get zero-shot learning, which basically means you figure things out, you learn new things just by thinking about it, basically by cognitive processes, you know, sort of essentially inference. You have a number of pieces of information and then from that you synthesize them and you actually come up with some new piece of information. And that's also related to automatic concept formation being able to you know see a few examples of of something you know i've never seen a trike before or something you know and then you see something with three wheels and you have just you know very few examples and you can form this new concept you may have seen bicycles before and
所以基本上有三波 AI。我们发现这是一个非常有用的模型。第一波 AI 是人们所说的“老派 AI”（GOFAI），也就是几十年来在 AI 领域所做的一切。这包括深蓝（Deep Blue）成为世界国际象棋冠军。它基本上围绕专家系统、形式逻辑等事物。而且，很多 AI 基本上就是那样做的，狭义 AI。这就是第一波。
cars and you know whatever and you can form that concept very quickly. Somebody could even explain it to you that you've never seen one before. You know, you've never seen a trike before. Somebody says, yeah, it's something like a bicycle or motorcycle, but it has, you know, two wheels at the back or at the front or whatever the case may be. So, yeah. Now, of course, the other side of things, and actually, interestingly, DARPA, a few years ago, started giving some presentations that they talk about the third wave of AI,
第二波浪潮大约在八九年前像海啸一样袭来，当时人们终于弄清楚了如何以非常非常令人印象深刻的方式使用神经网络，部分原因归功于大公司积累的海量数据，这是以前从未有过的，以及巨大的计算能力。所以之前缺失的两个要素就是海量数据和计算能力。
so that basically there are three waves of AI. And we find that quite a useful model. And the first wave of AI is what people call good old-fashioned AI, which is basically all the stuff that was done for decades in AI. That would include Deep Blue basically being the world champion chess game. It's basically centered around expert system, formal logic, and things of that nature. And, you know, a lot of AI was basically done that way, narrow AI. And that's the first wave.
然后对算法进行了一些调整。这确实带来了深度学习的革命，也就是机器学习的专业领域。那是一场真正的革命。根据 DARPA 的说法，这就是第二波 AI。但第三波基本上就是我们所说的认知架构或认知。我不能称之为认知计算，因为 IBM 窃取了这个术语并把它搞砸了。是的，没错。但是，它基本上是拥有认知能力。它能够学习和推理，有趣的是，这又回到了 AI 最初的理想，即 60 多年前这个术语被创造出来时，基本上可以交互式学习，
And the second wave hit us like a tsunami about eight, nine years ago when people finally figured out how they could use neural networks in a very, very impressive way, partially down to just the massive amounts of data that large companies had accumulated that they never had before and the massive amount of computing power. So two of the ingredients that were missing before is having that massive amount of data and computing power.
使用上下文，即随着变化而变化的动态上下文，并进行交互式学习和使用。是的，我认为有一件事会非常有用，那就是解释你刚才描述的内容与在线学习之间的区别。你可以有一个深度学习系统，在服务时将服务请求分批处理成小批量，并且存在一定的损失，因此模型在实时更新。但听起来这不足以涵盖你所说的那种适应性。不，我的意思是，模型实时更新，实际上你是在构建一个新模型。我不知道，显然，无论我说什么，每当你谈论
And then a few tweaks to the algorithms. And that really is what brought us the revolution of deep learning, you know, the specialized field of machine learning. And that's been a real revolution. And that is the second wave of AI, according to DARPA. But the third wave is basically what we would call cognitive architectures or cognitive. I can't call it cognitive computing because IBM stole that term and messed it up. Yeah, that's right. But, you know, it's basically having cognition. It's being able to learn and reason, which, interestingly enough, is sort of full circle going back to the original ideal of AI, when the term was coined 60-odd years ago, that's can basically, you know, learn interactively,
机器学习、深度学习的局限性时，显然都有人们正在努力克服这些限制的例子。所以，这里有一篇论文，那里有一个实验系统等等。所以，你不能说它做不到。是的，可能有一些一次性学习。但确实没有真正的增量式实时学习。我不知道有任何系统能做到这一点，因为，正如你所说，它是在分批处理。
use context, you know, dynamic context as it changes and learn and use interactively. Yeah, I think one thing would be really useful is explaining the difference between, you know, what you've just described and just online learning, right? So you could do, you could have a deep learning system that is, you know, at serving time, it's batching serving requests up into mini batches, and there's some loss there, and so the model is updating in real time. But it sounds like that's not, you know, that's not sufficient to cover the kind of adaptability you're talking about. No, I mean, the model updating in real time, I mean, it's really you're building a new model. I don't, you know, there's obviously, you know, whatever I say, whenever you talk about
所以你已经把东西放进了你的桶里。它变成了一个统计汤。所以“我姐姐的猫 Spock”会在那个训练模型中丢失。而且它必须发生，不仅仅是分批，而是实时。我的意思是，我们现在进行的对话，任何对话，我们可能不会记住对方说的每一句话，但通常对话有一个基于所说内容、我们的想法、目标等的轨迹。所以，模型确实需要随着你听到的每一件事瞬间更新。
limitations of machine learning, deep learning, there are obviously examples where people are working on overcoming those limits. So, you know, there's a paper here and an experimental system there and so on. So, you know, you can't say it can't be done. Yes, there's probably some one-shot learning. But there really isn't truly incremental real-time learning. I don't know of any system that could do that because, you know, you already called it as batching up.
如果你无法理解它，比如“我姐姐的猫 Spock 怀孕了”，而孩子不知道“怀孕”是什么，孩子可能会停下来问：“那是什么？”是的，没错。它无法整合这一点。所以我们在网站上有一个例子，我们谈论我们自己版本的 Alexa。基本上它背后的“大脑”，我们说：“把鳄梨酱（guac）加到我的购物清单上。”然后 Aigo 说：“什么是 guac？我不知道 guac 是什么。”“哦，guac 和鳄梨酱（guacamole）是一样的。”所以系统需要足够聪明，知道自己不知道什么，然后能够自动消除歧义。而不是当你说“给 Bob 打电话”时，它说“你是说列表里的这个 Bob 还是那个 Bob”，因为有人硬编码了它。它需要是一种内在的认知能力，
So you're already putting things into your bucket. It becomes a statistical soup uh you know so you know my sister's cat spock isn't is going to get lost there you know uh yeah that's right in that training model and and it has to happen uh not just in batches but in real time i mean just the conversation we're having now any conversation you you, you know, we may not remember everything that the other person said, but generally, you know, the conversation has a trajectory based on what was said, you know, what we think, what the objective is, and so on. And so, you really, the model needs to be updated instantaneously with everything that you hear.
当系统得到输入且不知道如何解释时，它基本上听不懂，或者存在歧义，它需要当场处理，就像我们在对话中必须做的那样。如果你进行重要的对话，有时我们都会掩盖过去，听不懂对方在说什么。
And if you can't make sense of it, so, you know, if you let's say my sister's cat, Spock, is pregnant and the person, the child didn't know what pregnant was, you know, the child might stop and say, what is that? Yeah, right. It couldn't integrate that, you know. So we have an example on our website, for example, where, you know, we talk to, we have our own sort of version of Alexa. Basically, the brain behind it, you know, we say, put guac on my shopping list, you know. And then Aigo says, well, what is guac? I don't know what guac is, you know. Oh, you know, guac is the same as guacamole. So it's all the system needs to be smart enough to know what it doesn't know and to then be able to, you know, automatically disambiguate. And not some hard-coded thing when you say, you know, call Bob and it says, do you mean Bob this, Bob that from your, you know, from your list because somebody hard-coded it, but it needs to be an inherent cognitive capability
好吧，没关系。我们会继续。但如果你真的想进行有用的对话，你最好理解对方实际说了什么以及他们的意思。如果它有歧义或者你不理解这个术语，你真的需要当场解决它。从这个意义上说，拥有一个知识图谱、一个不断更新的本体、一个推理引擎，这种认知架构确实是正确的方法。但当然，我们也知道老派 AI（专家系统）的局限性。这就是为什么我们需要第三波浪潮。主要是形式逻辑的脆弱性，这才是真正的杀手。是的，这很有道理。这里有很多东西需要拆解。我想，
that when the system gets input and it doesn't know how to interpret that, it basically doesn't understand it or there's an ambiguity, it needs to deal with it there and then, like we have to in a conversation. If you have an important conversation, sometimes we all gloss over it and we don't understand what the person is saying.
是的，实际上，让我们倒着来。所以你说的最后一件事，脆弱性，我认为这似乎是最大的问题之一。对于统计模型，你得到的是数百万种不同经验或数百万份不同文档的整合。所以如果你想象一下，谷歌图片搜索过去的工作方式是，他们查看图片，查看同一网页上的文字，他们会说这些东西是弱连接的。如果你有足够的网页，那种弱连接就会变得越来越强。所以，你可能在一个关于猫的页面上有一只狗，或者只是一个随机页面，一个关于宇航员的页面。但很有可能，在有“狗”和“犬”等词的页面上，你会看到更多的狗。
OK, fine. We'll move on. But if you really wanted to have a useful conversation, you better understand what the person actually says and what they mean. And if it's ambiguous or you don't understand the term, you really need to sort that out there and then. So in that sense, a good old-fashioned approach of having a knowledge graph, an ontology that gets updated, having a reasoning engine, sort of cognitive architectures are in that sense the right approach. But of course, we also know the limitations of good old-fashioned AI of expert systems. And that's really why we need a third wave. It's the brittleness, primarily of formal logic, that's really the killer there. Yeah, that makes sense. So there's a lot to unpack there. I think,
相比之下，在专家系统中，至少第一波专家系统，它们是脆弱的，因为它们无法处理混合情况，因为组合会导致组合爆炸。而且因为有很多“人在回路中”。我认为对于 OpenCyc，很多内容是由人编写的。我知道一些 DBpedia 和其他一些是从互联网上抓取的，但有很多手工工程。所以你认为我们将如何克服这一点，也许取这些传统上由人工策划的符号系统的精华，比如 WordNet，以及一些你使用大量电力但不需要大量人力投入的统计方法？
yeah, actually, well, let's kind of work backwards. So the last thing you said, the brittleness, I think that, yeah, that seems to be one of the big issues is, you know, with the statistical models, what you get is sort of this integration over millions of different experiences or millions of different documents. So if you imagine, so just some context the way google image search at least used to work is is um they would look at images and they would look at words on the same web page and they would say these things are weakly connected and if you have enough web pages um you know that weak connection can get stronger and stronger it's and so know, you might have a dog on a page about cats or just some random page, a page about astronauts or something. But chances are you have a lot more dogs on pages where you have the word dog and the word canine and things like that.
是的，我相信答案在于 DARPA 所说的第三波浪潮。描述它的一种方式是作为一种认知架构。所以你基本上从问自己“什么是智能”、“智能包含什么”开始。你可以列出一个实用的清单，我们已经谈到了一些关键点：能够交互式学习，能够深入理解并知道自己什么时候不懂，能够进行推理。所以这可能是三个关键点。你的架构必须从设计上就具备处理这些问题的能力。现在，一些认知架构已经存在了几十年，但它们并没有真正发挥作用。但它们没有发挥作用的主要原因，
And so versus, you know, in the expert systems, at least the, you know, the first wave, let's say expert systems, at least the first wave, let's say, expert systems, they were brittle in the sense that they couldn't, at least in my opinion, they couldn't handle mixtures very well because a combination of, you know, it causes this combinatoric explosion in the different possibilities. And also because there was a lot of sort of human in the loop. You know, I think for OpenPsych, a lot of sort of human in the loop um you know i think for open psych a lot of that is written by people um i know some dbpedia and some of these other ones have been kind of scraped off off the internet and um um but but you know there's a lot of hand
我想在这里插一句，神经网络也是人们研究了几十年，你可以说神经网络并没有真正发挥作用。是的，它们在发挥作用之前确实没用。直到有人弄清楚如何让它们工作。我相信这就是认知架构目前的处境。人们试图让它们工作，但它们没有工作，原因我相信我们很清楚。其中之一是它们基于形式逻辑。它们中的大多数，或者几乎所有，都基于形式逻辑。而形式逻辑，就像 Cyc 遇到的问题一样，无法处理矛盾的信息。
engineering there and so how do you think they're going to sort of we're going to sort of overcome that and maybe sort of i guess take the best of these sort of symbolic systems have been traditionally curated by hand and uh i like word net comes to mind right and and some of these statistical methods where you're using a lot of electricity but you're not using a lot of of human effort right right right um so the i mean i i believe the answer lies in what darpa calls the third wave you know and one way to describe it is as a cognitive architecture so you basically start off by asking yourself what is intelligence what does intelligence entail and you know you can kind of make a practical laundry list of things and you know we've already spoken about um some of the key ones is to be able to
工程方面，你认为他们将如何克服这个问题，或许如何汲取这些传统上由人工策划的符号系统的精华，比如WordNet，以及那些消耗大量电力但无需太多人力投入的统计方法？
learn interactively to be able to understand deeply understand and know when you're not understanding stuff and to be able to reason about things. So those are maybe three key things. And your architecture needs to inherently be designed to be able to cope with that. Now, some of the cognitive architectures have been around for a few decades and they haven't really worked that well. But primarily the reason they haven't worked,
交互式学习，能够深入理解并知道自己何时不理解，以及能够进行推理。这可能是三个关键点。你的架构设计必须从本质上能够应对这些需求。虽然一些认知架构已经存在了几十年，但它们并没有取得很好的效果。但它们之所以没能成功，主要原因是，
well, I just want to interject here, neural nets nets also for decades people worked on it and you could say well neural nets don't really work you know yeah they don't they don't work until they do you know yeah until somebody figures out how to get them to work and i i believe that's sort of the where we are with cognitive architectures you know people have tried to get them to work and they haven't worked for reasons which I believe we understand quite well. So one of the things is they are based on formal logic. Most of them are based, or pretty much all of them are based on formal logic. And formal logic, like the problem that Psych had, can't handle contradictory information.
嗯，我想在这里插一句，神经网络也是人们研究了几十年的课题，你也可以说神经网络并没有真正奏效，直到它们突然奏效了。直到有人找到了让它们运作的方法。我相信认知架构现在正处于这个阶段。人们尝试过让它们运作，但由于一些我们认为已经很清楚的原因，它们没能成功。其中一个原因是它们基于形式逻辑。大多数，或者说几乎所有这些架构都基于形式逻辑。而形式逻辑，就像Cyc项目遇到的问题一样，无法处理矛盾信息。
So what Psych ended up doing having micro domains where within the micro domain it had to be consistent but the the domains themselves didn't necessarily have to be consistent that's sort of roughly how they they dealt with that but that's that's not nearly fine-grained enough you know you you can um you know you can you can read that google bought deep mind for you know 400 million and and another article, Google bought DeepMind for $600 million. And you say, well, and your system really just needs to be able to take it in stride as we can. Okay, well, there's something not resolved until you find out the one was a newspaper report from the UK and the other one from the US. So the one was in pounds and the other one was in dollars.
所以 Psych 最终的做法是建立微域，在微域内必须保持一致，但域本身不一定非要保持一致，这大致就是他们处理这个问题的方式，但这还远远不够精细，你知道，你可以读到谷歌以 4 亿收购了 DeepMind，另一篇文章又说谷歌以 6 亿美元收购了 DeepMind。你会说，你的系统确实需要能够从容应对，就像我们一样。好吧，有些事情在没弄清楚之前是无法解决的，比如其中一篇是英国的报道，另一篇是美国的。所以一个是英镑，另一个是美元。
But in the meantime, you need to basically capture that knowledge and form a logic system which just fall apart, you know, if it had this contradictory information. You have fuzzy information, you know. You know, some guy is a short basketball player, you know. Hey, the poor guy is only 6'5 or something, you know. Yeah, right. So he's a short person, you know, hey, the poor guy's only 6'5 or something, you know. Yeah, right. So he's a short person, you know. So being able to contextualize what, you know, the meaning of things, those kind of things. So formal logic hasn't been able to deal with that.
但与此同时，你需要基本捕捉到这些知识并形成一个逻辑系统，如果它包含这种矛盾的信息，系统就会崩溃。你有模糊的信息，你知道。你知道，某个人是个矮个子篮球运动员，你知道。嘿，这家伙才 6 英尺 5 英寸左右，你知道。是啊，没错。所以他是个矮个子，你知道，嘿，这家伙才 6 英尺 5 英寸左右，你知道。是啊，没错。所以他是个矮个子，你知道。因此，能够将事物的含义情境化，诸如此类的事情。所以形式逻辑一直无法处理这些问题。
So the answer lies in basically having a knowledge representation and a logic engine, a reasoning engine that can inherently deal with contradictions, with fuzziness in an effective way. So I think that that's really the way to go. Now, the question you asked about not having a human in the loop to get the knowledge, this is really, really tricky. We as humans just pick up such an enormous amount of common sense knowledge, you know, even a two-year-old has it, about how the world works. And to get that knowledge represented properly in an AI is really, really hard. And especially if you don't have embodiment, you know, if it's not actually a robot that crawls around or walks around in the real world and learns. Do you feel like it's genetic?
所以答案在于建立一种知识表示和逻辑引擎，一种能够从本质上有效处理矛盾和模糊性的推理引擎。所以我认为这确实是未来的方向。现在，你问到的关于没有人类参与来获取知识的问题，这真的非常非常棘手。我们人类只是获取了海量的常识性知识，你知道，即使是两岁的孩子也知道世界是如何运作的。要将这些知识适当地表现在人工智能中真的非常非常困难。尤其是如果你没有具身性，你知道，如果它不是一个在现实世界中爬行或走动并学习的机器人。你觉得这是遗传的吗？
Do you think that a lot of this information is multi-generational and it's encoded in that way? Or do you think that we are able to really kind of bootstrap? Because, yeah, the two-year-old thing blows my mind, or even just a baby is able to have so much common sense reasoning. You know, I don't have any data, but just like intuitively, it feels like there's got to be some kind of genetic stamp there. Yeah, I think there is. And that's, you know, it's kind of a very difficult thing to unpack, basically, nature versus nurture.
你认为这些信息很多是跨代的，并且是以这种方式编码的吗？还是你认为我们真的能够实现某种自举？因为，是的，两岁孩子的事情让我大吃一惊，甚至只是一个婴儿就能拥有如此多的常识推理能力。你知道，我没有任何数据，但凭直觉，感觉一定有某种遗传印记。是的，我认为有。而且，你知道，这基本上是一个非常难以拆解的问题，即先天与后天的关系。
And so we're clearly not a blank slate. You know, babies are not a blank slate. That's for sure. But is there, you know, are we born with knowledge? I don't think there's evidence that we are born with knowledge per se. But again, it's very tricky. Where do you draw the line of what you call knowledge? I mean, a baby knows where it's going to get fed, what it needs to do to get milk.
所以我们显然不是一张白纸。你知道，婴儿不是一张白纸。这是肯定的。但我们是否天生就拥有知识？我不认为有证据表明我们天生就拥有知识本身。但同样，这非常棘手。你如何界定你所说的知识的界限？我的意思是，婴儿知道去哪里进食，知道需要做什么才能喝到奶。
So it has those instincts that are obviously obviously in DNA as they are for animals. But I think the biggest part is, so yes, there are some built-in instincts that, you know, allow us to survive and kind of bootstrap ourselves. But I think the bigger thing is sort of built-in feature extraction. And I think the very good example, a very obvious example there is, you know, in our visual system that we basically clearly have feature extraction for, you know, lines, for vertical or horizontal lines. If we didn't have that, we'd have a much, much harder time being able to, you know, recognize objects and to basically to get our visual system to be effective. You know, I'm not an expert on what all the feature extractors are,
所以它拥有那些显然存在于 DNA 中的本能，就像动物一样。但我认为最主要的部分是，是的，有一些内置的本能，你知道，让我们能够生存并实现某种自举。但我认为更重要的事情是某种内置的特征提取。我认为一个非常好的例子，一个非常明显的例子是，你知道，在我们的视觉系统中，我们显然对线条，对垂直或水平线条有特征提取能力。如果我们没有这些，我们在识别物体以及让我们的视觉系统有效工作方面会困难得多。你知道，我不是所有特征提取器方面的专家，
but clearly there is hard-coded feature extraction that helps to get us going. So from an AI point of view, to get back to that, it'll be a combination of having to kind of hard code, you know, preload the system with enough information to bootstrap itself. And, you know, that's kind of one of the things we're doing in our company. I've been working on the project now for more than 20 years. And, you know, the approach we use, we call artificial general intelligence, as opposed to narrow AI. I actually coined the term AGI together with two other people in 2001,
但显然存在硬编码的特征提取，帮助我们起步。所以从人工智能的角度来看，回到这一点，这将是必须进行某种硬编码的结合，你知道，预加载系统足够的信息以实现自举。而且，你知道，这正是我们在公司所做的事情之一。我已经在这个项目上工作了 20 多年。而且，你知道，我们使用的方法，我们称之为通用人工智能，而不是狭义人工智能。实际上，我在 2001 年与另外两个人一起创造了 AGI 这个术语，
to make that distinction that narrow AI is really not what we're after. You know, narrow AI, you take the intelligence that the human has, we were talking about human in the loop, you take the intelligence that the human has and you're turning that into code, or you take the intelligence, the insights that the human has to help you build a model that you can then deploy. But it's really the human intelligence that's being turned into code or model. The intelligence doesn't reside in the code or in the model, at least not to a significant extent. So artificial general intelligence is all about building systems that can learn more
为了做出这种区分，即狭义人工智能并不是我们所追求的。你知道，狭义人工智能，你获取人类拥有的智能，我们刚才谈到了人类参与，你获取人类拥有的智能并将其转化为代码，或者你获取人类拥有的智能和洞察力来帮助你构建一个可以部署的模型。但实际上是人类智能被转化为了代码或模型。智能并不存在于代码或模型中，至少在很大程度上不是。所以通用人工智能的核心在于构建能够学习更多的系统
and more by themselves. But you need a certain level of bootstrapping that basically the system can hit the books, as it were, and hit Wikipedia and actually have enough of of a background understanding to make sense of what is actually reading you know yeah i mean i think in the you know in the in the deep reinforcement learning or let's say reinforcement learning community you know there's there's world building models there's there's sim to real right so in this case there's examples where you say, you know, given the current state of, let's say, my robot, I'm going to predict if I take this
并且能够自主学习。但你需要一定程度的自举，基本上系统可以像读书一样去查阅维基百科，并且拥有足够的背景理解力来理解它正在阅读的内容，你知道，是的，我的意思是，我认为在深度强化学习，或者说强化学习社区中，你知道，有世界构建模型，有模拟到现实，对吧？所以在这个案例中，有一些例子，你说，你知道，给定我机器人的当前状态，我将预测如果我采取这个
action what the next state's going to look like. And so I'm going to build this state to state function, right? And then there's even embed to control where I'm going to say, okay, the state is kind of difficult to output because maybe it's some sparse state. Maybe it's a graph or something like that. I'm going to embed this state in this latent space. And in this latent space, I can have simulators. I can hallucinate in this latent space all these alternatives, right? And so people are trying to do that, you know, that sort of sim to real idea.
动作，下一个状态会是什么样子。所以我将构建这个状态到状态的函数，对吧？然后还有嵌入到控制，我会说，好的，状态很难输出，因为也许它是一些稀疏状态。也许它是一个图之类的东西。我将把这个状态嵌入到这个潜在空间中。在这个潜在空间中，我可以拥有模拟器。我可以在这个潜在空间中幻觉出所有这些替代方案，对吧？所以人们正在尝试这样做，你知道，那种模拟到现实的想法。
But again, it's this soup, right? I mean, what you're left with is this really odd, you know, embedding of, let's say, Pac-Man and the Pac-Man universe. And it's completely uninterpretable. And it's whether it adapts or not is unknown unknown i mean it's it you can't know that in advance um and you can't extract uh you know a knowledge graph or anything meaningful from it at least not not not uh directly right um and so yeah i i guess you know how does the cognitive architecture allow you to sort of build upon allow it to be sort of agglometric and continue to build on itself? Right.
但同样，这就像一锅粥，对吧？我的意思是，你剩下的是这种非常奇怪的，你知道，嵌入，比如吃豆人（Pac-Man）和吃豆人宇宙。而且它是完全不可解释的。它是否适应是未知的，我的意思是，你无法提前知道这一点，嗯，你无法从中提取知识图谱或任何有意义的东西，至少不能直接提取，对吧，嗯，所以是的，我猜，你知道，认知架构如何允许你构建它，允许它成为某种聚合式的并继续自我构建？对。
You know, without falling back to this embedding soup thing. Right, right. I got from philosophy, epistemology, theory of knowledge, that is really crucial in understanding, trying to figure out how to build the systems, is the importance of concepts. And that is basically how your knowledge is represented. Deep learning machine learning systems basically optimize on whatever features they can use, minimal features they can use to to categorize something. So, you know, if orange pixels are the thing to categorize it, then so be it. But it may be that all your examples were orange things, you know, and when you get across the green, there's the famous army tank example. Right. You built a model for this to detect Russian versus U.S. tanks. When they took pictures of the Russian tanks, it was at night.
你知道，而不回落到这种嵌入粥的状态。对，对。我从哲学、认识论、知识论中了解到，这对于理解、试图弄清楚如何构建这些系统至关重要，那就是概念的重要性。这基本上就是你的知识是如何表示的。深度学习机器学习系统基本上会优化它们可以使用的任何特征，它们可以用来对某事物进行分类的最小特征。所以，你知道，如果橙色像素是分类的依据，那就这样吧。但可能你所有的例子都是橙色的东西，你知道，当你遇到绿色时，有一个著名的陆军坦克例子。对。你建立了一个模型来检测俄罗斯坦克与美国坦克。当他们拍摄俄罗斯坦克照片时，是在晚上。
And so the model ended up being a nighttime predictor instead of a Russian tank. Exactly. That's right. Whereas humans, we we extract. What are the essential features in a contextual basis and, you know, what we want to form the concept for. And yes, in your example of the tank, yes, the fact that it's day or night is totally irrelevant. So therefore, that's not a feature that we would encode for a tank. And we know that because of the background information that we have and the purpose of why, you know, this is all subconscious, of course. We know what this concept is supposed to be for, used for, and that can adapt, that can change over time.
所以模型最终成为了一个夜间预测器，而不是俄罗斯坦克预测器。完全正确。就是这样。而人类，我们提取的是。什么是情境基础上的基本特征，你知道，我们想要为之形成概念的东西。是的，在你的坦克例子中，是的，它是白天还是晚上完全无关紧要。因此，这不是我们会为坦克编码的特征。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们拥有的背景信息以及我们为什么要这样做，当然，这一切都是潜意识的。我们知道这个概念应该是为了什么，用于什么，而且它可以适应，可以随时间改变。
You know, you may, as a child, the concept of a dog or a cat may be, you know, I had something to play with and, you know, can bite you or whatever, you know, the case may be. But then you become a vet and suddenly the concept changes very, very dramatically, you know, in terms of what kind of cat is it, you know, what what it looked like and can you detect a particular ailment or whatever. So the concepts themselves can also change and adapt to the use that you want to put the concept to. But the concepts themselves need to represent the key features, the essential features for the purpose that you're trying to put it to. But in addition to it, you also embed it in that you have the concrete examples so you can fall back on the concrete examples you know when you when when for example that and you know we don't have photographic memory and but certain things we do remember well so you know if that first picture of a giraffe really made a big impact on a child,
你知道，作为一个孩子，狗或猫的概念可能是，你知道，我有一个可以玩的东西，而且，你知道，会咬你之类的，你知道，情况可能是这样。但后来你成为了兽医，突然间概念发生了非常非常巨大的变化，你知道，就它是哪种猫而言，你知道，它看起来像什么，你能检测出某种特定的疾病之类的。所以概念本身也可以改变并适应你想要赋予该概念的用途。但概念本身需要代表关键特征，即为了你试图将其用于的目的而必需的基本特征。但除此之外，你还将它嵌入到具体的例子中，这样你就可以回溯到具体的例子，你知道，当例如那个，而且，你知道，我们没有照相记忆，但某些事情我们确实记得很清楚，所以，你知道，如果那张长颈鹿的第一张照片真的给孩子留下了深刻的印象，
then it can probably recall that picture. It'll still have the example. And yet at the same time, it'll have a representation of a giraffe that has extracted the essential features, you know, the long neck, the long legs. That's the essential feature that makes it obviously different from other animals. You know, it obviously different from other animals you know it's an animal but you know what is different one elephant with a big trunk and big ears you know those are really the key features that makes sense and so the way you figure out the way you it's the frame problem right so you look at a giraffe and there's a million things you could say about this giraffe but until you look at a bunch of other animals it's hard to know what separates this giraffe from the other animals like if you're in the savannah you might start by saying oh well giraffes are yellow but then you
那么它可能还能回忆起那张照片。它仍然会有那个例子。然而同时，它也会有一个长颈鹿的表示，提取了基本特征，你知道，长脖子，长腿。这就是使其明显区别于其他动物的基本特征。你知道，它明显区别于其他动物，你知道它是一种动物，但你知道有什么不同，一只长着大鼻子和大耳朵的大象，你知道，这些才是真正有意义的关键特征，所以你弄清楚的方式，它是框架问题，对吧？所以你看着一只长颈鹿，关于这只长颈鹿你可以说一百万件事，但除非你看看其他一堆动物，否则很难知道是什么将这只长颈鹿与其他动物区分开来，比如如果你在稀树草原上，你可能会从说，哦，好吧，长颈鹿是黄色的开始，但然后你
find that lions are more or less yellow or i guess brown and tigers are or not lionesses are brown maybe warthogs are brown it's okay maybe you say okay color is maybe not the defining characteristic of the giraffe right um and and so how i imagine this and i'm definitely not an expert in the cognitive architecture although i want to be after this after hearing the talk so far it sounds really exciting but but uh it sounds like you have this sort of this like quantum, almost like quantum superposition of all of these things that could be interesting. And over time, you're having to sort of refine that and continue to update that. Yeah, exactly. I wouldn't put it anywhere as mysterious as, you know, quantum phenomena. Yeah, right.
发现狮子或多或少也是黄色的，或者我猜是棕色的，老虎是，或者不是，母狮子可能是棕色的，也许疣猪是棕色的，好吧，也许你会说，好的，颜色也许不是长颈鹿的定义特征，对吧，嗯，所以我对此的想象是，我绝对不是认知架构方面的专家，尽管在听了到目前为止的演讲后我想成为，这听起来真的很令人兴奋，但但嗯，听起来你拥有这种类似于量子，几乎是量子叠加态的所有可能有趣的东西。随着时间的推移，你必须对其进行某种提炼并继续更新它。是的，完全正确。我不会把它说得像量子现象那么神秘。是的，没错。
But absolutely, you can basically, as you see, also one of the other problems with deep learning statistical systems is they throw away the examples. The instances are not encoded. So whereas in a cognitive architecture, it's cheap and easy, you know, with memory to actually have a photographic memory and remember the original sentence that you heard the utterance in or the sentences that you heard. So you have the original instance or with images, you have the original image. So you could then retrospectively refine or redefine what the essential features are. You know, you might, as you say, the giraffe might be the first yellow animal you see. And so you think maybe yellow is like really key. But, you know, as you see other animals, you know that yellow is not a distinguishing feature. And then you see toy animals which could be purple or, you know, purple unicorns or whatever.
但绝对地，你可以基本上，正如你所见，深度学习统计系统的另一个问题是它们丢弃了例子。实例没有被编码。而在认知架构中，它既便宜又容易，你知道，用内存来实际拥有照相记忆并记住你听到话语的原始句子，或者你听到的句子。所以你拥有原始实例，或者对于图像，你拥有原始图像。因此，你可以随后回顾性地提炼或重新定义什么是基本特征。你知道，你可能，正如你所说，长颈鹿可能是你看到的第一种黄色动物。所以你认为也许黄色真的很关键。但是，你知道，当你看到其他动物时，你知道黄色不是一个显著特征。然后你看到玩具动物，它们可能是紫色的，或者，你知道，紫色独角兽之类的。
Right. Pink elephants. You say, well, yeah, actually, you have that subconcept of, yeah, anyway, you have that overlapping concept of toys, which, you know, automatically have some different kind of weird features that can modify the other features. You know, they can be a completely different size, they're much smaller, they're soft, they don't bite you, and they can be a weird color. But you can still tell
对。粉色大象。你说，好吧，是的，实际上，你拥有那个玩具的子概念，你知道，它自动具有一些不同的奇怪特征，可以修改其他特征。你知道，它们可以是完全不同的大小，它们小得多，它们很软，它们不会咬你，而且它们可以是奇怪的颜色。但你仍然可以区分
a giraffe from an elephant, a toy elephant, by just extracting using different features within that context. Yeah, that makes sense. So one thing, so a lot of these systems you're building, you have to have conversations or are designed to have conversations with real people. And so humans have set up kind of our own vocabulary, our own sort of common sense
长颈鹿和大象，玩具大象，通过在那个情境中提取使用不同的特征。是的，这说得通。所以有一件事，所以你构建的许多这些系统，你必须进行对话，或者被设计为与真实的人进行对话。所以人类已经建立了我们自己的词汇，我们自己的一种常识
reasoning. And that might not be optimal or even close to it, but it's sort of it is what it is. If you want to talk to a human, you're going to have to use the sort of common sense atoms that a human would use. Right. And so how do you sort of reconcile that? I imagine if you if you really started from scratch saying we're going to build this kind of knowledge graph, then it's going to say, oh, you know, giraffes have, you know, a bend in their ear and other animals don't. But no person would ever think about a giraffe in that way, right? How do you deal with that disconnect? Right, right. It's a very interesting question because when I started on the project, initially we were in pure R&D mode.
推理。那可能不是最优的，甚至离最优还很远，但它就是这样。如果你想与人类交谈，你将不得不使用人类会使用的那种常识原子。对。那么你如何调和这一点呢？我想如果你真的从零开始说我们要构建这种知识图谱，那么它会说，哦，你知道，长颈鹿耳朵有一个弯曲，而其他动物没有。但没有人会以那种方式思考长颈鹿，对吧？你如何处理这种脱节？对，对。这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为当我开始这个项目时，最初我们处于纯研发模式。
We basically took the ideas that I'd come up with of cognitive architecture and built various prototypes. So we had a virtual mouse living in a virtual environment and learning, you know, it had, you know, virtual ears and nose and whiskers and so on, and to basically to learn in the environment. And we then had different prototypes with different animals, dogs, and then we had child, and we tried that. And then we decided we would focus on natural language, you know, but at adult level, basically. And so we spent several years teaching the system a whole lot of different things
我们基本上采用了我想出的认知架构的想法，并构建了各种原型。所以我们有一只生活在虚拟环境中的虚拟老鼠，并且在学习，你知道，它有，你知道，虚拟耳朵、鼻子和胡须等等，基本上是在环境中学习。然后我们有针对不同动物的不同原型，狗，然后我们有孩子，我们尝试了那个。然后我们决定专注于自然语言，你知道，但基本上是成人水平。所以我们花了好几年时间教系统很多不同的东西
that we thought it should know, the kind of background knowledge it should know. But then when we commercialize, when you try to now use the system in a real life situation that's going to do a job, a useful job, you actually in a way have to dumb down the system. Yeah. job, you actually, in a way, have to dumb down the system. But it's actually not that different from you might be offshoring your call center operations, you know, and you don't want the person in wherever they are in India or Philippines or whatever say, hey, I know how to sell this product much better than my boss told me to do. And, you know, I'll go off script and just do that. No, no. You want the person to stay on script, you know. Yeah. That's what the company has learned. So
我们认为它应该知道的，它应该知道的那种背景知识。但后来当我们商业化时，当你现在试图在现实生活中使用该系统来完成一项工作，一项有用的工作时，你实际上在某种程度上必须降低系统的智能。是的。工作，你实际上在某种程度上必须降低系统的智能。但这实际上与你可能将呼叫中心业务外包并没有什么不同，你知道，你不想让身处印度或菲律宾或其他任何地方的人说，嘿，我知道如何销售这个产品，比我老板告诉我的要好得多。而且，你知道，我会脱离剧本去做。不，不。你希望那个人保持在剧本上，你知道。是的。这就是公司所学到的。所以
we need to basically constrain Igo to stay on script, as it were, and to say things that people would expect and to listen for things that we would expect people to say at that time and not try and learn new things, you new things and form new concepts. So in that sense, you're kind of dumbing the system down for that. So the kind of research passed to give a true open intelligence and the commercial practicalities do tend to diverge, and that's one of the challenges I've had since commercializing it is to make sure we can still continue cranking up the IQ and make the system more and more
我们需要基本上限制 Igo 保持在剧本上，正如我们所说，并说人们会期望说的话，并倾听我们期望人们在那个时候说的话，而不是试图学习新事物，你新事物并形成新概念。从这个意义上说，你是在某种程度上降低了系统的智能。所以那种通往真正开放智能的研究路径与商业实用性确实往往会分道扬镳，这也是我自商业化以来面临的挑战之一，即确保我们仍然可以继续提高智商，使系统越来越
intelligent, but without it going off script, so to speak, you know, without it trying to be too clever and obviously not clever enough. So that's kind of one of the challenges. And I actually call it the AGI trap, that to build a commercial system, it's almost always easier to hard code things and to do them in a narrow way than to try and do them in a sort of really cognitive architecture way. And so we need to strike that balance.
智能，但又不至于脱离剧本，可以说，你知道，不至于试图表现得太聪明，显然又不够聪明。所以这算是挑战之一。我实际上称之为 AGI 陷阱，即构建一个商业系统，硬编码某些东西并以狭隘的方式去做，几乎总是比尝试以某种真正的认知架构方式去做要容易。所以我们需要达到那种平衡。
So yeah, you pointed on a very important issue there that general intelligence at a baby level is not that useful. Yeah, right. And I think there's that actually, you could extrapolate that to a lot of different domains. And look at robotics, uh you know people are so worried about robots taking over jobs but it's it's not just that the robot has to be able to do the job but it has to be able to be more efficient than a person i mean if if you have a robot but it's going to require uh you know i don't know twenty dollars an hour worth of you know maintenance and maybe it fails every now
所以是的，你指出了一个非常重要的问题，即婴儿水平的通用智能并不是那么有用。是的，没错。而且我认为实际上，你可以将其推断到许多不同的领域。看看机器人技术，嗯，你知道人们非常担心机器人接管工作，但这不仅仅是机器人必须能够完成工作，它还必须能够比人更有效率，我的意思是，如果你有一个机器人，但它需要，嗯，我不知道，每小时 20 美元的维护费用，而且也许它每隔一段时间就会失败
and then. And well, then then and if it's doing a job that you could, you could have someone do for $15 an hour, then that's no good, right. And so I think you can find almost any domain where what you said is true. I mean, even if you look at video games, so so video game AI, you could spend a ton of time, you know, I mean, my PhD was on playing various games and you could spend a ton of time making a really complicated video game opponent. zone and it's much easier to do that by having a knob it's like if the person's doing too well then you just crank up the knob and there's just more of the same dumb enemies show up next time you know right right yeah no it's i mean the way our the way we're thinking about it is to our goal is to get closer and closer to human level capabilities, because I believe it's going to be enormously beneficial to humanity to have that. And we're sort of bootstrapping it through kind of a skeleton where the system, we hard code, well, we're not hard code, we don't code it,
一次。好吧，那么，如果它正在做一份你可以让某人以每小时 15 美元的价格完成的工作，那么这就没用了，对吧。所以我认为你可以在几乎任何领域发现你所说的是正确的。我的意思是，即使你看看电子游戏，所以电子游戏人工智能，你可以花大量时间，你知道，我的博士学位是关于玩各种游戏的，你可以花大量时间制作一个非常复杂的电子游戏对手。区域，而且通过有一个旋钮来做到这一点要容易得多，就像如果那个人做得太好，那么你只需调高旋钮，下次就会出现更多同样的愚蠢敌人，你知道，对，对，是的，不，我的意思是，我们思考它的方式是我们的目标是越来越接近人类水平的能力，因为我相信这对人类来说将是非常有益的。而且我们正在通过某种骨架来引导它，系统，我们硬编码，嗯，我们不是硬编码，我们不编码它，
but we teach the system sort of rough common sense knowledge in an ontology. But we know that knowledge is not the way it should be represented, but it's kind of just to help it bootstrap. So think of it as like a scaffolding that the system should then build its real knowledge around the scaffolding, and eventually the scaffolding itself just dissolves because it now has, it's acquired the knowledge in a way that it really should have acquired it in the first place you know so that's kind of how we we see the bootstrapping process to higher and higher levels of intelligence but it's it's hard yeah i mean i make sense i mean i think you know you see this in the real world i mean in in with real human
但我们教系统在本体中某种粗略的常识知识。但我们知道知识不应该是那样表示的，但这只是为了帮助它自举。所以把它想象成一个脚手架，系统应该围绕这个脚手架构建它真正的知识，最终脚手架本身就会溶解，因为它现在已经，它以它本来应该获取的方式获取了知识，你知道，所以这就是我们看待通往更高和更高智能水平的自举过程的方式，但这很难，是的，我的意思是，这说得通，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，你在现实世界中看到了这一点，我的意思是，在与真正的人类
beings and you see this in uh industry settings as well, where in the real world, you don't let your child put his hand on the stove. You don't let them learn that the hard way, right, or stick a fork in a socket or something. So what that means is they're not going to fully understand what it means to sort of put your hand on the stove until they're older and they understand heat and what heat could do to things and so on and so forth. But the alternative is someone gets seriously hurt. So you kind of have to sort of bias someone's knowledge, right? And what you see in industry sort of decision-making systems is something similar where, like, for example, if you were to build a system to decide how many ads to show on a Google landing page, right, it might want to try to fill the whole page full of ads, right? Because that could be interesting. But that would kind of hurt your brand, right? And so you kind of have to start with, you know,
在一起时，你在工业环境中也看到了这一点，在现实世界中，你不会让你的孩子把手放在炉子上。你不会让他们以那种方式学习，对吧，或者把叉子插进插座之类的。所以这意味着在他们长大并理解热量以及热量会对事物造成什么影响等等之前，他们不会完全理解把手放在炉子上意味着什么。但另一种选择是有人受到严重伤害。所以你必须在某种程度上偏向某人的知识，对吧？而在工业决策系统中，你所看到的是类似的情况，比如，如果你要构建一个系统来决定在谷歌着陆页上显示多少广告，对吧，它可能想尝试填满整个页面的广告，对吧？因为那可能很有趣。但这会损害你的品牌，对吧？所以你必须从，你知道，
something that's very focused, very guided, and then allow kind of a little bit of creativity. And then, as you said, eventually, you know, as the system starts to learn and reason, especially starts to reason counterfactually and starts to be able to understand, oh, if I filled the page full of ads, no one would come back, right?
非常专注、非常引导的东西开始，然后允许一点点创造力。然后，正如你所说，最终，你知道，随着系统开始学习和推理，特别是开始反事实推理并开始能够理解，哦，如果我用广告填满页面，就不会有人再来了，对吧？
If you can reason that from a limited set of experiences, then you can sort of, you know, take the training wheels off. Right, right. Yeah, absolutely. Those guardrails need to be there. But it's having an architecture, having an approach that inherently allows you to increase the level of intelligence and to, you know, that has the features that are needed for intelligence. Yeah, so one last sort of technical question, and we should definitely jump into iGo as a company, as a product, and as a place to work. So, you know, how do you sort of,
如果你能从有限的经验中推理出这一点，那么你就可以，你知道，拆掉辅助轮。对，对。是的，绝对。那些护栏必须存在。但拥有一个架构，拥有一个本质上允许你提高智能水平的方法，并且，你知道，拥有智能所需特征的方法。是的，所以最后一个技术问题，我们绝对应该跳到 Igo 作为一家公司、作为产品和作为工作场所的话题上。所以，你知道，你如何，
it sounds like the cognitive architecture is, it's an evolution, but it's also kind of a unification of the past. Right. You have these knowledge graphs, these these sort of symbolic systems. You have the sort of primordial embedding soups. And this is sort of, you know, taking kind of the best of all of that, where you're using statistics and reasoning and and things that that you've observed to sort of have this living knowledge graph and then are you the part that i wasn't totally clear about yet is are you also then using uh the expert systems approach like using search and ir methods on that graph that you're that you're updating in real time is Is that part of it? Yeah, I mean, from a practical
听起来认知架构是，它是一种进化，但它也是过去的一种统一。对。你拥有这些知识图谱，这些符号系统。你拥有那种原始的嵌入粥。这基本上是，你知道，取其精华，你正在使用统计数据和推理以及你观察到的东西来拥有这种活的知识图谱，然后你，我还没完全弄清楚的部分是，你是否也正在使用专家系统方法，比如在该图谱上使用搜索和信息检索方法，你正在实时更新它，这是它的一部分吗？是的，我的意思是，从实际
point of view, and that could be, you know, other people may have a sort of, what should I call it, a cleaner theoretical approach than we have. You know, I'm as much a businessman as I am a scientist or researcher. And so to me, I look at it as an engineering thing, is what's the best way of getting it done? You know, what's the best piece of technology or algorithm or whatever I can use to get a particular component to operate efficiently? Now, if you took a theoretically cleaner approach,
的角度来看，这可能是，你知道，其他人可能拥有某种，我该怎么称呼它，比我们更纯粹的理论方法。你知道，我既是商人，也是科学家或研究员。所以对我来说，我把它看作是一个工程问题，什么是完成它的最好方法？你知道，我能用来让特定组件高效运行的最好的技术或算法或任何东西是什么？现在，如果你采取一种理论上更纯粹的方法，
you might say, well, no, we can't use a brute force approach because the brain doesn't do it or it shouldn't really be using it or because ultimately not going to be scalable or whatever. So I'm less concerned about that. And we'll use search for some of our algorithms. So we'll use whatever tricks in the book. This is hard enough. We don't want to say that because this is not theoretically as clean as you might like to have it.
你可能会说，好吧，不，我们不能使用暴力破解方法，因为大脑不这样做，或者它真的不应该使用它，或者因为最终它不会是可扩展的等等。所以我不太关心那个。我们将为我们的一些算法使用搜索。所以我们将使用书中的任何技巧。这已经够难了。我们不想说，因为这在理论上不像你可能希望的那样干净。
We've got to get it to work. So, yeah, so we'll use, we'll use whatever we need, but the, the, the core foundation that we found is, is really having a knowledge graph and having the right knowledge representation, knowledge representation that has the flexibility to deal with contradictions and with fuzziness with limb, you know, and, and, and um and context and and so on and that knowledge graph has to be super high performance uh that's uh just i'll talk a little bit about why cognitive architectures haven't worked up to now um and i can mention three reasons uh for it one of them is the brittleness of good old-fashioned ai of of you know formal formal logic most of them is the brittleness of good old fashioned AI of, you know, formal logic.
我们必须让它工作。所以，是的，所以我们将使用，我们将使用我们需要的一切，但我们发现的核心基础，确实是拥有一个知识图谱并拥有正确的知识表示，这种知识表示具有处理矛盾和模糊性、限制，你知道，以及情境等等的灵活性，而且那个知识图谱必须是超高性能的，嗯，那只是，我会谈谈为什么认知架构到目前为止还没有奏效，我可以提到三个原因，其中之一是老派人工智能的脆弱性，你知道，形式逻辑，大多数是老派人工智能的脆弱性，你知道，形式逻辑。
Most of them tried to get away with formal logic and they just hit a wall on that. The second thing that we're finding, we've spoken to quite a few labs that are trying to do conversational AI and to use knowledge graphs interactively in the conversation, you know, to basically get context and to update the knowledge graph and to basically use it interactively in real time. And they found they had severe performance issues. So we developed a knowledge graph technology that's two orders of magnitude faster than any commercially available graph database, 100 times faster. And that makes all the difference that basically, you know, where you could have a sub-second response to something that somebody says, you know, versus having a, you know, 500, you know, 50-second response, you know, a minute response, which clearly is unacceptable.
他们大多数人试图用形式逻辑来逃避，但他们只是撞上了那堵墙。我们发现的第二件事，我们已经与相当多的实验室谈过，他们正在尝试做对话式人工智能，并在对话中交互式地使用知识图谱，你知道，基本上获取情境并更新知识图谱，并基本上实时交互式地使用它。他们发现他们有严重的性能问题。所以我们开发了一种知识图谱技术，比任何商业可用的图数据库快两个数量级，快 100 倍。这使得一切都不同了，基本上，你知道，你可以对某人说的话有亚秒级的响应，你知道，而不是有一个，你知道，500，你知道，50 秒的响应，你知道，一分钟的响应，这显然是不可接受的。
Because we might hit that knowledge graph hundreds of times or thousands of times while we're trying to make sense of an utterance. So those are two reasons that the performance of the knowledge graph and not being constrained by formal logic approaches, those are two reasons. But the third one is actually more an accident of history. And that is that nobody's working on cognitive architectures. And why is that? Well, primarily because deep learning has been so incredibly successful in so many areas. So it sucked all of the oxygen out of the air. I remember when I was studying deep learning, it was in the deep learning winter. So I got my PhD in 2009, and you actually couldn't publish a paper in deep learning.
因为当我们试图理解话语时，我们可能会成百上千次地访问那个知识图谱。所以这是两个原因，知识图谱的性能和不受形式逻辑方法的约束，这是两个原因。但第三个原因实际上更多是历史的偶然。那就是没有人致力于认知架构。为什么会这样？嗯，主要是因为深度学习在许多领域都取得了令人难以置信的成功。所以它吸走了空气中所有的氧气。我记得当我学习深度学习时，那是在深度学习的冬天。所以我 2009 年获得博士学位，你实际上无法在深度学习领域发表论文。
You couldn't submit a deep learning paper to NIPS. They would reject it. It would have to be truly remarkable to get into NIPS. And now all of NIPS has just neural networks applied to everything. And to your point, I mean, I think that's the goal of academic or, you know, in this case, like a company that's really forward thinking is to do that thing that nobody else is doing. So I think that's pretty cool. Yeah. And it's, I mean, we had, as a concrete example, we had a brilliant intern from Germany working on our project quite a few years ago. And he really got the cognitive architecture concept and, you know, he, you know, and understood the thing.
你无法向 NIPS 提交深度学习论文。他们会拒绝它。它必须真正非凡才能进入 NIPS。而现在整个 NIPS 只是神经网络应用于一切。说到你的观点，我的意思是，我认为这就是学术界的目标，或者，你知道，在这种情况下，像一家真正具有前瞻性的公司，就是做那些没有人做的事情。所以我认为这很酷。是的。而且，我的意思是，我们有一个具体的例子，我们有一位来自德国的杰出实习生，几年前在我们项目上工作。他真的理解了认知架构的概念，而且，你知道，他，你知道，并且理解了那个东西。
Was with us for a year, went back to Germany to do his PhD on that. He couldn't get a sponsor. He ended up doing a PhD in deep learning, you know. Yeah, yeah. Want to earn the big bucks. You want to get your paper published. You want to, you know, get a PhD. You want to earn the big bucks, you want to get your paper published, you want to get a PhD, you want to get funding for your company, deep learning is the only game in town.
和我们在一起一年，回到德国去攻读博士学位。他找不到赞助商。他最终在深度学习领域攻读了博士学位，你知道。是啊，是啊。想赚大钱。你想发表你的论文。你想，你知道，获得博士学位。你想赚大钱，你想发表你的论文，你想获得博士学位，你想为你的公司获得资金，深度学习是城里唯一的游戏。
So all of the big decision makers at the big companies and the VC firms and that, they're obviously all deep learning, that's the only game in town. So that's actually, quite frankly, one of the big reasons I believe that cognitive architectures haven't made much more progress. And, you know, I've just been blinkered. I mean, I spent five years doing my own research before I started on this project to really deeply understand what intelligence entails. You know, how does our intelligence differ from animals? How do children learn? What do IQ tests measure? Are they meaningful? I studied epistemology, you know, theory of knowledge, and even what is reality? What is our relationship of our knowledge and
所以大公司和风投公司的所有大决策者，他们显然都是深度学习，那是城里唯一的游戏。所以这实际上，坦率地说，我认为这是认知架构没有取得更大进展的主要原因之一。而且，你知道，我一直被蒙蔽了。我的意思是，在开始这个项目之前，我花了五年时间做我自己的研究，以真正深入理解智能包含什么。你知道，我们的智能与动物有何不同？孩子是如何学习的？智商测试测量什么？它们有意义吗？我研究了认识论，你知道，知识论，甚至什么是现实？我们的知识与
certainty to reality? And really deeply understanding cognition from, you know, all these different angles from cognitive psychology and and of course the different fields of ai and um and then you know i came to conclusion okay we need you know what i now call a cognitive architecture and it's just been so obvious to me that that's required there's no shortcut you know that it has to learn interactively in real time one shot. That's not negotiable, you know. And if you're working on any system, if you're not solving that problem, you're not going to get an intelligent system. It's as simple as that, you know.
确定性对现实的关系是什么？并从，你知道，所有这些不同的角度，从认知心理学，当然还有人工智能的不同领域，真正深入理解认知，嗯，然后你知道，我得出了结论，好的，我们需要，你知道，我现在称之为认知架构的东西，对我来说，这显然是必需的，没有捷径，你知道，它必须实时交互式地学习，一次性学习。这是不可协商的，你知道。而且如果你正在研究任何系统，如果你没有解决那个问题，你就不会得到一个智能系统。就这么简单，你知道。
So a generally intelligent system and a few other things like that. And that's why I've been blinkered working on this with limited budget. I was fortunate enough to have a good commercial success with a software company I formed, did an IPO on that. So that gave me enough time and money when I exited that company to actually embark on this project and i've been been able to fund it you know with with about a dozen people uh doing research and then we commercialized the first generation and now for the last six years we've been working on the second generation on i go ai and but it's uh you really have to be certain that this is the path. Like some of the pioneers of
所以一个通用智能系统和其他一些类似的东西。这就是为什么我一直被蒙蔽，在预算有限的情况下致力于此。我很幸运，我创办的一家软件公司取得了良好的商业成功，并进行了首次公开募股。所以这让我在退出那家公司时有足够的时间和金钱来真正着手这个项目，而且我一直能够资助它，你知道，有大约十几个人在做研究，然后我们商业化了第一代，现在在过去的六年里，我们一直在致力于第二代，致力于 Igo AI，但这，你真的必须确定这就是路径。就像深度学习的一些先驱一样，
deep learning, we're sure that deep learning or neural nets of some sort were really, really powerful and useful eventually, and they turned out to be right. Yeah. I mean, one of the things I've been talking a lot about at work for years, and we haven't really been able to make progress, is this idea of if you have an embedding, you're recovering like an English explanation of that embedding. So imagine if you have an embedding of all of a person's activity on Amazon, could you write a bio about that person, right? Like, could you just take that embedding and output, emit a bio, this is Bob, Bob loves soccer products, and Bob buys things in the evening, right?
我们确信深度学习或某种神经网络最终会非常、非常强大和有用，结果证明他们是对的。是的。我的意思是，多年来我在工作中一直在谈论的一件事，我们还没有真正取得进展，就是这个想法，如果你有一个嵌入，你正在恢复像该嵌入的英文解释。所以想象一下，如果你拥有一个人在亚马逊上所有活动的嵌入，你能写一篇关于那个人的传记吗，对吧？就像，你能直接获取那个嵌入并输出，发出一个传记，这是鲍勃，鲍勃喜欢足球产品，鲍勃在晚上买东西，对吧？
And again, of course, you could do it with a lot of human engineering, but the thought experiment here is, could we just organically you know go backwards like you can clearly you know there are encoders that could clearly embed english uh and translate it into french we've seen that um but but could you do more could you embed could you encode experiences and translate them into english right and i And I think that is something that's proving to be extremely difficult. And I think what we're starting to realize
当然，你可以通过大量的人工工程来做到这一点，但这里的思想实验是，我们能否有机地，你知道，向后走，就像你可以清楚地，你知道，有编码器可以清楚地嵌入英语，并将其翻译成法语，我们已经看到了这一点，嗯，但但你能做得更多吗？你能嵌入，你能编码经验并将其翻译成英语吗，对吧？而且我认为这正在被证明是非常困难的。而且我认为我们开始意识到
is maybe something you've realized for a long time, which is that symbolic representations, they're not things that can be just omitted from embeddings. And these are things that have to kind of work together in harmony. Yeah, well, well i mean the example you giving is actually a very very powerful one is could you do it and i think the way um statistical systems are set up i mean even the fact that they're statistical immediately negates that possibility because you are trying to average out of, you know, many instances of what is the average thing that happens.
的是，也许是你很久以前就意识到的事情，那就是符号表示，它们不是可以简单地从嵌入中省略的东西。这些东西必须以某种方式和谐地协同工作。是的，好吧，我的意思是，你给出的例子实际上是一个非常非常强大的例子，你能做到吗？而且我认为统计系统设置的方式，我的意思是，即使它们是统计性的这一事实也立即否定了那种可能性，因为你正在试图平均掉，你知道，许多发生的事情的平均情况。
So you have to lose the original instance information. So therefore, you couldn't reconstruct it. You could only reconstruct the average. And one of the, you know, huge failures of or limitations, I shouldn't call it failure because they're not trying to do that. But limitations is you can't deal with the outliers. You know, if my profile says, you know, my personal profile of what I buy or what I do, my activity, let's just for argument's sake, say it has a 99% confidence that I would be interested in cricket. I lived in South Africa before.
所以你必须丢失原始实例信息。因此，你无法重构它。你只能重构平均值。其中一个巨大的失败或局限性——我不应该称之为失败，因为他们并不是想做那个——但局限性在于你无法处理异常值。你知道，如果我的个人资料显示，比如我买什么或做什么，我的活动，我们假设一下，它有99%的置信度表明我对板球感兴趣。我以前住在南非。
Oh, okay. Well, there you go. Whatever. I drink tea. I love tea. So whatever. My profile, let's just for argument's sake. But I don't care for cricket at all.
哦，好吧。原来如此。随便吧。我喝茶。我喜欢茶。所以随便吧。我的个人资料，我们假设一下。但我一点也不关心板球。
But my profile would suggest that the statistical system can simply not deal with that. I mean, all of them require regularization to perform. I mean, that was one of the big, one of the hallmarks of deep learning was dropout and was batch norm and ways to eliminate outliers. It's their strengths. But therefore, you can then never deal with these outliers, the people that don't fit the statistic. And this is also one of the reasons why it can inherently not work in an ongoing conversation. I mean, apart from the sort of example I gave that you have to learn in real time. But even putting that apart, setting that apart, you know, if you have a lot of sort of the normal kind of conversation, if a statistical system has an 85% accuracy or something, you know, on what response
但我的个人资料会显示统计系统根本无法处理这个问题。我的意思是，它们都需要正则化才能运行。我的意思是，深度学习的标志之一是Dropout和批归一化，以及消除异常值的方法。这是它们的优势。但因此，你永远无法处理这些异常值，即那些不符合统计数据的人。这也是它本质上无法在持续对话中工作的原因之一。我的意思是，除了我给出的那种你必须实时学习的例子之外。但即使撇开这一点不谈，你知道，如果你有很多那种正常的对话，如果一个统计系统有85%的准确率或者类似的东西，你知道，在回答什么方面
to give, well, if you have a conversation and you three or four or five sentences into the conversation, you multiply the 85%. Yeah. Yeah. You know, you're down to gobbledygook, basically, you know. Yeah. It's not designed toledygook basically you know yeah it's not designed to recover either as you said it's not designed to ask the pointed questions to yeah let's say hey i'm lost here you know you know explain that to me so um yeah some and and there's there's actually kind of one last thing i'd just like to come back because you've mentioned a few times the relationship between embeddings and and symbolic and yeah so they're the problems of how information is encoded in deep learning systems that it's not encoded in a conceptual format but it's you need to have it in a conceptual
该给出什么，嗯，如果你进行对话，并且你已经进行了三、四或五句对话，你就会乘以85%。是的。是的。你知道，你基本上就陷入了胡言乱语，你知道。是的。它也不是为了恢复而设计的，正如你所说，它不是为了问尖锐的问题，比如“嘿，我在这里迷路了，你能向我解释一下吗”。所以，是的，还有一件事我想回来谈谈，因为你提到了几次嵌入和符号之间的关系，是的，所以它们是信息如何在深度学习系统中编码的问题，它不是以概念格式编码的，但你需要它以概念
format to be able to then link it to the symbols because the symbol refers to the concept but the concept itself has to be represented in the in the right way with the right features you know and that's why um yeah it will think that uh you know this stop sign is a fridge or whatever, you know. Yeah, right. One thing that I saw from Google that really resonated with me was early on in the embeddings, this was maybe 2011, you know, deep learning was still kind of catching on.
格式才能将其链接到符号，因为符号指的是概念，但概念本身必须以正确的方式用正确的特征来表示，你知道，这就是为什么它会认为这个停车标志是一个冰箱之类的，你知道。是的，没错。我从谷歌看到的一件事真的引起了我的共鸣，那就是在嵌入的早期，这可能是在2011年，你知道，深度学习还在流行起来。
And the person, I can't remember their name. Patrick, you would know this. The person who is the MacGyver of Google, totally drawing a blank. There was a whole page. Jeff Dean. Thank you, yeah. So Jeff Dean came and gave a talk on embeddings, and they actually were trying to draw symbolic inferences from embeddings. So, for example, you could minus king from queen and you could minus lion from lioness and you would get
那个人，我不记得他的名字了。帕特里克，你会知道的。那个谷歌的麦盖提（MacGyver），完全想不起来了。有一整页。杰夫·迪恩。谢谢，是的。所以杰夫·迪恩来做了一个关于嵌入的演讲，他们实际上试图从嵌入中得出符号推论。所以，例如，你可以用女王减去国王，用母狮减去狮子，你会得到
the same vector, right? And that seems so powerful, but in a way, you know, now in hindsight, you know, we have 10, 9, 10 years of hindsight, that was quite the red herring, wasn't it? Because it really suggested that you had the symbols there, you just had to do some algebra to get them. And here we are 10 years later with almost no progress, right? Yeah. I'm actually so glad you mentioned that because I love talking about that exact example that it was seen as a revolution. And I always called it a parlor trick because that's exactly the examples I gave. You could take Paris, subtract France and add England and you'd get London or whatever. When this first came out, we actually tried to use – this is word to vector basically.
相同的向量，对吧？这看起来非常强大，但在某种程度上，你知道，现在回想起来，我们有9年、10年的回顾，那真是一个误导，不是吗？因为它确实暗示了你拥有那些符号，你只需要做一些代数运算就能得到它们。而10年后的今天，我们几乎没有任何进展，对吧？是的。我真的很高兴你提到了这一点，因为我喜欢谈论那个确切的例子，它被视为一场革命。我一直称它为一种江湖骗术，因为那正是我给出的例子。你可以拿巴黎，减去法国，加上英国，你就会得到伦敦之类的。当这个刚出来的时候，我们实际上尝试使用——这基本上就是Word2Vec。
We actually tried to use it in our system to see you know could we kind of would it help us bootstrap the system and we very very quickly found out what that it actually wasn't not only wasn't it useful it was actually counterproductive and i can give you a simple counter example that in vector space cats and dogs are much closer together than dog and puppy. Yeah, probably. Because in text, you'll find cats and dogs mentioned and not dogs and puppies, usually in the same sentence. And, you know, you very quickly find those kind of limitations. So even, yeah, it's sort of just a parlor trick just a politic that's wow yeah you yeah it seemed amazing
我们实际上尝试在我们的系统中使用它，看看它是否能帮助我们引导系统，我们很快发现它不仅没有用，实际上还适得其反。我可以给出一个简单的反例：在向量空间中，猫和狗比狗和幼犬更接近。是的，可能吧。因为在文本中，你会发现猫和狗通常在同一个句子中被提到，而不是狗和幼犬。而且，你很快就会发现这些局限性。所以即使是这样，它也只是一种江湖骗术，那真是太棒了，是的，它看起来很神奇
you you hit another point which yeah substitution is devastating to embeddings because it it it uh if one word can be substituted for another you'll rarely see them together and then that drives them apart but they're actually the same exact concept right right yeah but interesting times we live in you know yeah i mean this is super cool i mean i i definitely you know what you said really resonated with me uh having having having been a big proponent of of of uh of you know multi-layer perceptrons back when they weren't popular and i do think that do think that we do need sort of, we do need to stepwise advance. I think we're starting to hit the limit.
你提到了另一点，是的，替换对嵌入来说是毁灭性的，因为它如果一个词可以被另一个词替换，你很少会看到它们在一起，然后这会把它们分开，但它们实际上是完全相同的概念，对吧？是的，但我们生活在有趣的时代，你知道，是的，我的意思是这太酷了，我的意思是，我绝对，你知道你所说的真的引起了我的共鸣，作为一个在多层感知器不流行时就支持它们的人，我确实认为我们需要逐步推进。我认为我们开始触及极限了。
I mean, GPT-3 is so many gigabytes, right? Every time I see models get really large, it's a sign that we're starting to run out of low-hanging fruit. And so I'm really excited to see, yeah, I'll definitely be doing a bunch of reading on this. And I think you have a bunch of posts on Medium with some really good content. So what we'll do is we'll put that in the show notes so that folks can read more about this area. Great. Yeah, that'll be good.
我的意思是，GPT-3有这么多千兆字节，对吧？每次我看到模型变得非常大，这都是一个信号，表明我们开始用尽容易摘到的果实了。所以我很高兴看到，是的，我肯定会对此进行大量的阅读。而且我认为你在Medium上有很多内容非常好的文章。所以我们会把这些放在节目说明中，以便大家可以阅读更多关于这个领域的内容。太棒了。是的，那会很好。
And welcome any questions, feedback on that. I have quite a few articles on medium.com, including risks of AI and ethics and so on. Cool. So tell us a little bit about the company. So you told us it was founded, I think you said, 20 years ago? My first R&D company was in 2001 that I founded, first R&D company. We then launched a commercial, our first generation commercial product in 2008, a company called Smart Action. Smart Action is now about 100 people or so. Okay.
欢迎提出任何问题和反馈。我在medium.com上有很多文章，包括人工智能的风险和伦理等等。酷。那么给我们介绍一下这家公司吧。所以你告诉我们它是，我想你说，20年前成立的？我的第一家研发公司是在2001年成立的，第一家研发公司。然后我们在2008年推出了商业产品，我们的第一代商业产品，一家名为Smart Action的公司。Smart Action现在大约有100人左右。好的。
And, you know, providing an IVR with a brain. But I found that the commercial pressures of providing a SaaS service, you know, reliably, you know, with security and redundancy and performance and integration and all of that, that kind of sucked up all of the time and energy. And we really didn't spend any more time on cranking up the IQ because that wasn't sort of the bottleneck in the company. So I exited that company seven years ago and started iGo.ai so that I could concentrate again on cranking up the IQ. So I hired a new team of 12 people. I have an awesome team now. And we basically, for five, six years, we were just in development mode, not in R&D mode because we'd already done the research, but we knew what needed to be done
而且，你知道，提供一个有大脑的IVR。但我发现提供SaaS服务的商业压力，你知道，可靠地，你知道，伴随着安全性、冗余性、性能和集成等等，这几乎耗尽了所有的时间和精力。我们真的没有花更多时间来提升智商，因为那不是公司里的瓶颈。所以我七年前退出了那家公司，创办了iGo.ai，这样我就可以再次专注于提升智商。所以我雇了一个12人的新团队。我现在有一个很棒的团队。我们基本上有五、六年时间处于开发模式，而不是研发模式，因为我们已经完成了研究，但我们知道需要做什么
to basically make the system more intelligent, more capable. And then about a year or so ago, I got to a point where I said, okay, we're now ready to commercialize the second generation. And that's basically what Igo AI. And we just launched late last year officially. And we're now fully in commercial mode. We're 16 people right now.
来基本上使系统更智能、更有能力。大约一年前，我到了一个地步，我说，好吧，我们现在准备好商业化第二代了。这基本上就是Igo AI。我们去年年底正式推出。我们现在完全处于商业模式。我们现在有16个人。
We're actually aggressively hiring right now. So we hope to be hundreds of people in the not-too-distant future. Cool. So where's the company located? We're in Los Angeles. Okay, cool. Yeah, we're an exciting time. So while I said earlier, the commercial thing sort of pushes you in a different direction from just focusing on
我们实际上正在积极招聘。所以我们希望在不久的将来能有数百人。酷。那么公司位于哪里？我们在洛杉矶。好的，酷。是的，我们处于一个激动人心的时刻。所以虽然我之前说过，商业化某种程度上把你推向了与仅仅专注于
artificial general intelligence iq and so we very working very hard to balance that but the commercial activity is also a very very good reality check because you can have all of the theoretical things in the world you could write papers about it or beat benchmarks or do whatever, you know, ultimately the rubber hits the road when you're trying to use it in the real world. So the commercial aspect I find invaluable, but we just need to, from what we learned previously, is we need to make sure that we have enough resources to keep our development team going full speed while we also, you you know commercializing and getting that that that feedback and the money yeah yeah yeah oh yeah totally yeah did you have two sort of separate branches like a fundamental research branch and uh i guess the company is
通用人工智能智商不同的方向，所以我们非常努力地平衡这一点，但商业活动也是一个非常非常好的现实检验，因为你可以拥有世界上所有的理论东西，你可以写关于它的论文，或者打破基准，或者做任何事情，你知道，最终当你试图在现实世界中使用它时，橡胶就会撞击路面。所以我发现商业方面是无价的，但我们只需要，从我们之前学到的，我们需要确保我们有足够的资源让我们的开发团队全速前进，同时我们也，你知道，商业化并获得那种反馈和资金，是的，是的，哦，是的，完全是，是的，你有两个独立的部门吗，一个基础研究部门和一个，我想公司是
still smaller but as it grows yeah right right now i mean the people we have, we're all hired for the development roles. But as we've gone commercial, they've all been very excited to be part of the commercial team. But yes, we'll be separating it more as we move forward. But we don't want to silo them. We want to make sure that there's a lot of cross-communication for sure. Yeah, one of the biggest follies I've seen in research labs is where the communication only goes one way. So the idea is you have this fundamental research team, and they're going to write papers, and they're going to email the papers over to the applied.
仍然较小，但随着它的成长，是的，现在，我的意思是，我们拥有的人，我们都是为开发角色雇佣的。但随着我们走向商业化，他们都非常兴奋能成为商业团队的一员。但是的，随着我们前进，我们会更多地分离它。但我们不想把他们孤立起来。我们想确保确实有很多交叉沟通。是的，我在研究实验室看到的最大愚蠢行为之一是沟通只向一个方向进行。所以想法是，你有一个基础研究团队，他们会写论文，然后他们会把论文通过电子邮件发送给应用团队。
Yahoo is like this. So there's Yahoo Research. They would send the paper to Yahoo Labs, who would like this. So there's Yahoo research. They would send the paper to Yahoo labs who would then try to fit it into different products. But then no communication went the other way. And so that actually hurt the research team more than anybody because they were just operating kind of in the dark. Yeah, in a vacuum. Yeah. So we're in a fortunate position that, you know, I'm said as much of a businessman as I am cognitive scientist or AI scientist. So I'm really super excited about both aspects. And, you know, so being able to guide that from the top, you know, that to make sure they don't get siloed will definitely help us. Yeah, totally. So if there's folks right
雅虎就是这样。所以有雅虎研究院。他们会把论文发送给雅虎实验室，他们会试图将其应用到不同的产品中。但没有沟通向另一个方向进行。所以这实际上比任何人都更伤害研究团队，因为他们基本上是在黑暗中运作。是的，在真空中。是的。所以我们处于一个幸运的位置，你知道，我既是一个商人，也是一个认知科学家或人工智能科学家。所以我对这两个方面都超级兴奋。而且，你知道，所以能够从高层引导这一点，你知道，确保他们不会被孤立，肯定会帮助我们。是的，完全正确。所以如果现在有学生在大学里，你们在招聘吗？你们通常在寻找什么样的角色？你们有实习生吗？是的，所以我们过去也有过实习生，所以有可能。当然，现在有点棘手，因为在没有物理存在的情况下进行实习很难。所以我们还不知道结果会如何。但我们公司有趣的事情，这是非常不寻常的，70%的员工是我所说的AI心理学家。这实际上是我发明的一个职业。但他们基本上要么是语言学家，要么有语言学背景，要么有认知心理学背景。他们不是程序员。这再次是因为在我们的认知架构中，
now in university, are you hiring? What kind of roles in general are you looking for? Do you have internships? Yeah, so we have had interns in the past as well, so potentially. Of course, it's a little tricky right now because doing interns without physical presence is hard. So we don't know yet how that's going to pan out. But the interesting thing in our company, which is very unusual, 70% of our staff are what I call AI psychologists. It's actually a profession I invented. But they're basically either linguists, they either have linguistics training or cognitive psychology training. They're not programmers. And this is again, because in our cognitive architecture,
很多工作是通过训练IGO完成的，而不是编程IGO。所以，你知道，给它一个课程，构建本体，教学和执行任务。然后三分之一基本上是工程，你知道，我们进行实际的编码和集成等等。这说得通。是的。而且通常，我实际上更喜欢，这是一个概括，不是一个，你知道，不是我做的，我通常实际上更喜欢那些没有太多人工智能经验的人，因为否则有太多的东西需要忘记。
a lot of the work is being done through training IGO, not programming IGO. So, you know, giving it a curriculum, building the ontologies, teaching and having tasks. And then one third is basically engineering, you know, where we do the actual coding and integration and so on. That makes sense. Yeah. And typically, I actually prefer to, and this is a generalization, it's not a, you know, not as I do, is I generally actually prefer people who don't have a lot of AI experience because otherwise there's too much to unlearn.
是的，没错。是的，一切都会围绕着，你知道，什么是损失函数，什么是嵌入？我的意思是，你每天都会被问到这个问题。是的，完全正确。你知道，所以我们真的只是在寻找聪明、有动力，并且特别兴奋于从事这种项目的人，你知道，不想从事某种广告优化算法，或者你知道，无论什么，你知道，或者为狗粮做优步之类的。
Yeah, right. Yeah, everything will be framed around, you know, what's the loss function, what's the embedding? I mean, you just get asked that every day. Yeah, exactly. You know, so we're really just looking for people that are smart the loss function what's the embedding i mean you just get asked that every day yeah exactly you know so we're really just looking for people that are smart and motivated and that are particularly excited and working on on on this kind of project you know that don't want to work on some ad optimization algorithm or you know whatever you know or uber for dog food or whatever.
是的，狗粮优步。是的，所以我认为……那么你能走一遍这个工作……我的意思是，实际上，你所说的真的引起了我的共鸣，这个训练人工智能的想法。所以某人……我的意思是，显然有不同的角色。有DevOps，有优化数据库的人。所以这些角色，你知道，定义得很好。我想大多数关注这个节目的人都知道
Yeah, Uber for dog food. Yeah, so I think the... So can you kind of walk through what the job... I mean, actually, what you said really resonates with me, this idea of training the AI. So someone who... I mean, clearly there's different roles. There's DevOps, there's people who are optimizing the database. And so those roles are, you know, pretty well defined. I think most people who've been following the show know
那会是什么样子。但多告诉我一些关于训练的事情。我的意思是，这个AI心理学家，你说的？是的。所以那个人，一个典型的AI心理学家的一天是什么样的，你说的？是的，AI心理学家。所以那个人，一个典型的一天是什么样的？是的，所以其中有很多不同种类的专业，但它们都围绕着分析不同种类的对话场景。所以，我的意思是，在商业方面，在我们商业化之前，我们会编造我们自己的场景，比如“我姐姐的狗猫Spark怀孕了”，能够理解这一点，现在更像是，你知道，“我想更改我的订单上的送货地址”，你知道，那，是的，是的，你知道，或者“我的互联网服务有问题”，所以这是
what that's going to be like. But tell me more about the training. I mean, so this AI psychologist, you said? Yeah. So what is that person, what is a day like, a typical AI psychologist, you said? Yeah, AI psychologist. So what is that person, what is a day like, a typical day like for that person? Yeah, so there are quite a lot of different sort of specialities within that, but they all kind of revolve around analyzing different kinds of conversational scenarios. So, I mean, on the the commercial side before we were commercial we would make up our own scenarios like you know my sister's dog cat spark is pregnant and being able to understand that now it's more like uh you know i'd like to change the delivery address on my
歧义，希望通过上下文自动解决，基本上说，好吧，这里有一些模棱两可的东西，但我有可以消除歧义的上下文吗？然后基本上，系统是否已经拥有了有效进行消歧的知识和算法？而这种消歧也可以通过推理来完成。它可以是，你知道，“给鲍勃发一封电子邮件”，现在你可能会说，好吧，我知道两个不同的鲍勃，上下文可能没有告诉我，但可能还有其他你可以推理的事情，说，好吧，不可能是那个鲍勃，因为无论如何他死了，是的，没错，你知道，是的，所以可能有推理，或者上下文，或者其他什么，所以消歧，深度
order you know that yeah yeah you know or i'm having trouble with my internet service so it's Yeah, yeah. ambiguities, hopefully automatically through context, basically saying, okay, here's something ambiguous, but do I have the context that can disambiguate that? And then basically, does the system already have the knowledge and the algorithms to do the disambiguation effectively? And that disambiguation could also be done through reasoning. It could be, you know, send an email to bob um now you might say okay i know two different bobs the context may not tell me but there may be other things that you can reason about say well it can't possibly be that bob because whatever he died yeah right you know yeah so there could be reasoning uh or context or something so disambiguation deep
理解，我的一篇文章是理解理解，实际上有，或者上下文，或者其他什么。所以消歧，深度理解。我的一篇文章是理解，理解。实际上，这是一个非常有趣的话题，只是，你知道，理解包含什么。所以我们做的大部分工作是对人所说的话进行深度理解。但在行动方面，是，好吧，你如何回应它？有自然语言生成，你知道，或者执行某些技能，
understanding um one of my articles is understanding understanding there's actually or context or something. So disambiguation, deep understanding. One of my articles is understanding, understanding. There's actually, it's a very interesting topic, just, you know, what understanding entails. So a lot of the work we do is in deep understanding of what the person is saying. But then on the other action side of things is, okay, how do you respond to it? There's natural language generation and, you know, or doing certain skills,
执行某些任务，这可能需要子任务。系统知道如何执行这些子任务吗？我们需要教它吗？你知道，它需要收集更多信息来执行它吗？所以，你知道，例如，如果你说，你知道，我想更改我的订单上的送货地址，好吧，那么它可以执行该任务，但前提是它知道新的送货地址是什么。所以它会自动地，不需要我们编程，它应该知道这里有一条缺失的信息来执行这个任务。
doing certain tasks, which may entail subtasks. Does the system know how to do those subtasks? Do we need to teach it? You know, does it need to gather more information to do it? So, you know, for example, if you say, you know, I want to change the delivery address on my order, well, then it can do that task, but only if it knows what the new delivery address is. So it automatically, without us having to program it, it should know that here there's a piece of information that's missing to do this task.
我需要问，好吧，你想把地址改成什么，所以它基本上是在处理这个问题，并确保Aigo拥有正确的知识，然后突出显示基本的认知缺陷，你知道，我们说“嘿，Aigo应该已经能够自己弄清楚了”，但是，你知道，认知机制不够强大，然后，你知道，认知机制不够强大。然后，你知道，我们坐下来弄清楚，好吧，我们怎样才能让它更聪明，这样下次我们甚至不需要教它，它基本上已经可以自己弄清楚或者询问信息了。所以这是一种迭代过程。而且，是的，这是超级有趣的东西。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，你所说的很多
I need to ask, well, what would you like to change the address to so it's basically working through that and making sure that Aigo has the right knowledge and then highlighting fundamental cognitive deficiencies you know where we say hey Aigo should already be able to figure that out himself itself um but um you know the cognitive mechanisms aren't strong enough and then you know, the cognitive mechanisms aren't strong enough. And then, you know, we sit down and figure out, OK, how can we make it smarter so that next time we don't even have to teach it that it can basically already figure it out itself or ask for the information. So that's kind of the iterative process. And, yeah, it's super interesting stuff. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, a lot of what you
让我想起了，你知道，主动学习，对吧，你在寻找，我想我正在做我不应该做的事情。我回到了损失函数和所有这些。但这有点像你寻找那些在超平面上的东西。或者在这种情况下，你寻找那些系统完全模棱两可的东西，你试图，你知道，你试图明确地梳理出那些例子，对吧？完全正确，是的，酷，哇，那真是太疯狂了，所以，所以团队现在是集中的，它的办公室在洛杉矶。有什么增长计划吗？
said reminded me of, you know, active learning, right, where you're kind of looking for, and I guess I'm doing the thing that I shouldn't be doing. I'm going back to loss functions and all of that. But it's sort of like you look at, you sort of look for things that are on the hyperplane. Or in this case, you for things where um the system is entirely ambiguous and you you try to sort of uh uh you try to sort of tease apart those examples explicitly right exactly yeah cool wow that's uh that's totally wild um so so uh so the team right now is in is kind of centralized this its office in L.A. And is there any plans to grow?
所以如果有人，你知道，你们招聘的所有职位都在洛杉矶吗，有任何远程机会吗？是的，现在有。我们还没有弄清楚如何有效地互动和管理远程人员，但我相信我们会。我们只需要更多的管理结构等等。所以是的，现在我们每个人都在洛杉矶。酷。但这在不久的将来会有所改变，希望如此。是的，这说得通。酷。所以如果人们有问题，或者他们想写信给你关于，你知道，不同的，你知道，职业，我相信iGo.ai上有一个职业页面。所以人们先去看看那个。但如果他们有什么想和你聊的，他们怎么联系你？是的，medium.com，他们总是可以在那里回复。但我也很容易在Facebook上找到。
So if someone is, you know, are all the positions you're hiring for in L.A., are there any remote opportunities? Yeah, right now there are. We haven't yet figured out how to effectively interact and manage remote people, but I'm sure we will. We just need a bit more management structure and so on. So yeah, right now we have everyone in Los Angeles. Cool. But that'll change hopefully in the near future. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool. And so if people have questions or they want to write to you about, you know, different, you know, career, I'm sure there's a careers page on iGo.ai. So people check that out first. But if they have anything they wanted to chat to you about, how can they reach you? Yeah, medium.com would, they can always respond there. But I'm also easy to find on Facebook.
我在Twitter上。你知道，彼得·博斯，我想你会很容易找到我。酷。太棒了。非常感谢。这是一次绝对迷人的谈话。我肯定有很多研究要做。而且我相信听众们也有很多要做。有很多东西需要拆解。
I'm on Twitter. You know, Peter Boss, I think you'll be able to find me quite easily. Cool. Great. Thank you so much. This was an absolutely fascinating talk. I definitely have a lot of research to do. And I'm sure the listeners out there have a lot to do. There's a lot to unpack.
但是，你知道，我们有很多要做。有很多东西需要拆解，但我们有一个非常有动力的社区，所以我认为你真的让他们在下一年开始时就充满了动力，所以我很感激。太棒了。好吧，这很有趣。我很享受这次谈话。Programming Throwdown是分发的，谢谢。给帕特里克和我，分享和同类。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
But, you know, we have a lot to do. There's a lot to unpack, but we have a really motivated community and so I think you really kick-started them into the next year, so I appreciate it. Great. Well, this was fun. I enjoyed the conversation. Programming Throwdown is distributed Thank you. to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但，你知道，我们有很多要做。有很多东西需要拆解，但我们有一个非常有动力的社区，所以我认为你真的让他们在下一年开始时就充满了动力，所以我很感激。太棒了。好吧，这很有趣。我很享受这次谈话。Programming Throwdown是分发的，谢谢。给帕特里克和我，分享和同类。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。